Õpetaja: Share Screen või Sherscleen on peal. Juba ei ole,
Õpetaja: on, ei ole, Ahah. Nüüd Tuli ette mulle ka, et saab lisada.
Õpetaja: Natukene peegeldab mulle see peale.
Õpetaja: Davai. Ee, kolm sellel koolitusel huvitada.
Õpetaja: Oodake koera. Hästi, koera. Ee, Ma pean natukene vale asi. Õige asi
Õpetaja: Davai, Okei, ma vist. Ee. Vist sain aru, kes mõista.
Õpetaja: Jah, nii
Õpetaja: tahaks ühte pilti leida. Lihtsalt ülesse. Mul oli. Aa, see oli taskis Kuskil ka Tegelikult vist olemas.
Õpetaja: Kurat, ma ei tea ka. Okei, kohe kohe
Õpetaja: kohas.
Õpetaja: Search iga või olemas.
Õpetaja: Nii, ma näitan teile kohe midagi
Õpetaja: seda Seda kavalust kohe kohe. Ma tõmban alla. Kaks, kolm, asja, siis. Ee,
Õpetaja: nii, väga hea, pomm.
Õpetaja: Ee, niiöelda. Screenshare.
Õpetaja: Kuulge, lepime ruttu ühe asja ka kokku. Ee, mis kell Teeme pausi, Arvestades seda, et kuusteist. Aa, kakskümmend, Seitse Tõmbame juhtme seinast endal,
Õpetaja: et, ee, kus võiks paus olla. Ja kui pikk, Arutage senikaua.
Õpetaja: No, kuusteist. Kolmkümmend on lihtsam mõelda, onju?
Õpetaja: Kaksteist Kakskümmend sobib.
Õpetaja: Keegi hoiab silmad. Lahti.
Õpetaja: Aa, siis ma siis Ma ise ei pea sellele keskenduma. Davai Aa silmad lahti. Aa vaatamise kohta näete ekraani
Õpetaja: temp. Meil Ee, on keegi kasutand või midagi analoogset Aadress, millega on tegemist Euroopa Liiga
Õpetaja: tegemist on ajutise emailboksiga. Kuhu tulevad sisse emailid?
Õpetaja: Aga nagu on mainitud ajutine
Õpetaja: mingi kümme minutit kakskümmend minutit Tund aega, üks päev. Ma ei tea, Sõltub mingi kukidest taustal, või mis iganes on ju vahet pole, on vahel olnud kuskil, kus tahate nõutakse. Tahaksid justkui seda vaadata, Aga nagu Never. Again ei taha, et ka tuleb mingit risu, endale oleks ei taha. Nagu oma meili panna, hästi on seda olukorda olnud
Õpetaja: noh, see sama ongi. Ee, teeb meili. Ma panen siia kõrvale, aga samal ajal mina lähen teen niukse koha lahti nagu Balsamic Cloud
Õpetaja: Ee Googlest otsitav hetkel. Ma olen siin sees oma Glassmone. Iga pange tähele periodies. Expired
Õpetaja: Sa soovid seda Space I kasutada. Subscribe Now. No vaatan palju plekki. Ma peab üldse.
Õpetaja: Ah, kuidas oota,
Õpetaja: kindlasi vaadates?
Õpetaja: Subscribe Never. Nii, aga mis ta siis tegema peab? Ma vajutan korra.
Õpetaja: Esimene mai. Ee, ma ei viitsi nüüd pikalt näidata, Aga point on see, et teil on seal vaja regamiseks ainult meiliaadressi
Õpetaja: Ja need töötavad. Ma võin öelda, et igal pool ei tööta. Debmaili. Kuskil on mingid Ai D Filtrid juba vahel
Õpetaja: Ee. Ta nagu tahab Päris mingit email öelda saab aru, kas on fake või mitte. See polsamikus. Sa saad niikuinii regada. Aa, niiöelda koos fake mailiga. Neljateistkümneks Päevaks Nüüd tuleb välja kaheks nädala või neljaks nädalaks lausa, kui seda nuppu vajutada.
Õpetaja: Aa, et sellest piisab. Ja mis on eriti tore nende juures
Õpetaja: Nende teenuse juures. I love them I love them. Ee, Ma ei tea, kui nad ei ole seda läbi hammustanud juba või mitte. Ee, Siin on projektid. Ma korra kustutan need projektid ära. Mis siin on ja panen siit. Kus on Delete Selects
Õpetaja: teel Id.
Õpetaja: Just sellest Madis Rääkisime ka kohe. Nüüd näed, sealt saab mulle idee. Muidugi tuli ka. Vaata, et ma pole veel rääkinud ja õige koht seda teha,
Õpetaja: Meil On olemas niimoodi, et siin saad oma kuni kakskümmend projekti Siin saad nagu hoida tasuta.
Õpetaja: Ja. Ja mis on selle juures, Ee, Timm on See, et neil on eksport. Import feature.
Õpetaja: Mis see tähendab, Trael saab läbi enne seda eksport.
Õpetaja: Uus konto Import.
Õpetaja: Ervi ka
Õpetaja: Ma koguaeg hirmuga. Iga kord, kui ma siia login, ma mõtlen, millal See, nagu enam nii lihtne ei ole, et on vaja päris emaili, aga ma teeks Siis kasvõi lihtsalt kuhugi. Kuhu Iganes. Meiliaadressi. Kuigi tänapäeval. Nad vajavad mingit kuradi lollakat telefoninumbrit igal pool ka.
Õpetaja: Kui keegi leiab koha, kuidas saab lihtsalt teha päris emaile. Ee, kus ei ole vaja niiöelda telefoni. Ma pole midagi Chat it kunagi küsinud.
Õpetaja: Meil dot com on eesti turule keelatud. Ma ei viitsi mingi Vpn iga mässama hakata. Näete, mul on olemas siin mingi balsamic manager. Mingi Ma ei tea mida iganes nende laiendiga Niiöelda failid.
Õpetaja: Ee, kaks megabaiti kumbki. Näiteks korraga saab ta upload Ida. Proovime pulli pärast.
Õpetaja: Uploading Project. Ma pakun et ikka ühe saab korraga.
Õpetaja: Mõlemad veel korraga ka,
Õpetaja: kui meeldib. Nii, mul on siin kaks nii öelda projekti ja ma alustaksin. Ee, siis ma panen Open Project
Õpetaja: selle kohta.
Õpetaja: Mm, Palk Action Lihtsalt open open.
Õpetaja: Aga map. Aa, okei, lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: Kas panen selle aknaga kinni või? Või kannatama? Enamvähem sul pole Niiöelda vai
Õpetaja: nii Millega on tegemist? Ma lähen Nagu Demo režiimi, et saab proovida tegemist on keskkonnaga. Kus siis on võimalik disainida näiteks veebiä Mobiiliäpi, mistahes desktop tarkvara. Sest et päeva lõpuks on lihtsalt Mida sa visuaalselt näed?
Õpetaja: Me hakkame tegema panka õigemini pangaautomaatide asukohtade ee niiöelda mingit lehekülje, kus näitab, et noh, et tallinnas näiteks on siis mustamäe prismas, pangaautomaadid ja tondiselveris. Ja. Ja siis, mis seal tegevust saab, seal teha, Sularaha sisse, sularaha väljamakset ja nii edasi. Vahet pole, see on lihtsalt näidis. See on suvaline kruutnäidis.
Õpetaja: Me tahame teha läbi frontend I väga Backendi Aa tegevustega,
Õpetaja: kuidas andmeid lugeda. Ehk siis kuvada kuidas andmeid lisada. Kuidas andmeid uuendada kuidas andmeid kustutada? Need Asjad Mängime läbi, pluss mõned Fronti asjad, Mis, ee ka on head asjad, ja oletegi valmis tegema oma projekti.
Õpetaja: Kõigepealt teeme Fronti. Natuke. Teeme vahepeal Back I Võibolla ainult Selles mõttes, et õpime jaavat, aga ei tee projekti mingi hetk. Lülitame ümber, Teeme nii. Hakkame pihta. Ee, Kõige esimene vaade home see on Minu pank. Ja mida iganes see on, meie järgmine või taaskid peegeldavad neid samu pilte.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui see on meil tehtud siis on aeg edasi liikuda. Sisse logimine, mida näeb,
Õpetaja: siis see logimine. Menüüs, Kasutajanimi Parool Logi sisse. Ee, alert. Message vastavalt olukorrale. Täida kõik väljad või vale. Kasutaja nimi. Täida kõik välja, et front ise saab kontrollida. Vastab seda, et kui sa üritasid sisse logida, mingi jama ka
Õpetaja: on nii arusaadav, Siis liigume edasi. Logime sisse. Ee, läheme au. Pangaautomaadid Aa, vaatele lehele
Õpetaja: logi välja. Nupp tuleb siia. Logi sisse. Kaob ära. Vaade on esialgu. Tuleb lihtsalt tavaline jaoskript. Ja alert, mäletad? Tegime seda alerti ka. Tere, maailm ja muud asjad.
Õpetaja: Proof of concept. Et lihtsalt ära tõestada. Asjad töötavad, et me liigume ühelt vaatelt teisele. Need on erinevad failid ju Ja meil on olemas user Id ja admin väärtused,
Õpetaja: mille me saame Backendilt Nii, lähme edasi, siis läheme
Õpetaja: pangaautomaadid. Uus lehekülg. Oot, läks. Võtsid sassi. Ee, siis järgmisena tuleb meil, niimoodi, et pangaautoautode lehel on niukene Esimene valik on kõik linnad. Tallinn Tartu pärnu
Õpetaja: taustal on tegelikult need andmed tulevad. Kust Kohast
Õpetaja: Back endist Ja kus backhand saab? Need andmebaasist. Mis need on ideed?
Õpetaja: Id D. Igal real on kordumatul kujul. Sellest ka. Räägime oma Id järjest. Loendur. Kuidas andmeid lisatakse?
Õpetaja: Siin Näitel pärnu lisati esimesena. Siis läks Tallinn sinna Tabelisse ridade mõttes Tartu. Viimasena
Õpetaja: saate aru. Numbrid lihtsalt kasvavad. Seconds Counter.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis, ee. Teeme selle ära. See info tuleb backend teenuselt. Nüüd. Aa, miks alati tehti vanasti enne backend? Enne õpetati siis frontend. I No pole millegi vastu mängida. Mina Loen siin ära ühe pilveteenusega nimega Stop Idio,
Õpetaja: kus saad lihtsalt panna, et kui mina saadan sulle mingisuguse sõnumi, Mäletate need sõnumid, mis lähevad Urlidega. Nagu ka Brauseris.
Õpetaja: Kui mina saadan sulle sõnumi, siis sina kogu aeg. Osta mulle nii ja saan veel isegi natukene anda kaasa informatsiooni, Millist vastust? Anna Mulle Ise on pannud mingi näidisvastuse.
Õpetaja: Näiteks see informatsioon tuleb Jasoniga City. Ee City S. See tuleb Massiivina kandiliste sulgude vahel. City Name ja City Id City, Name ja City Id saate mõttest aru Nähtava osa peidetud osa. Sest nendega me tegeleme. Tegelikult me ei Soovi andmebaasis kunagi mingit stringe vaadata
Õpetaja: vaid neid indekseid. Sest enam kiiremini ei saa.
Õpetaja: Nii teeme selle ära, Siis on meil siin kena see Ee City Id, Mis tuleb sellest
Õpetaja: sellest väärtusest. Siin näitas City Id on hetkel null. Sellepärast, et kõik linnad on null, kui Aa, meil on pangaautomaadid. Loomulikult tuuakse info ära. Back endist. Informatsioon on ju, et kui kasutaja vajutaks näiteks Tallinn, siis City Id oleks kaks, on ju
Õpetaja: Ee, ja sellisel juhul
Õpetaja: olukord. Ee, siin muutub. Ist tuuakse jälle kõik andmed ära. Need andmed. Kus City Id on? Kaks.
Õpetaja: Kui keegi valib Tartu,
Õpetaja: siis tuleb Tartu City Id iga kolm. Kui keegi valib pärnu. Lihtsalt ainult harjutamise mõttes. Päriselus lihtsalt võiks tabel tühi olla.
Õpetaja: Noh, et ei leidnud midagi, aga veel tahame alertida. Ei leitud ühtegi pangaautomaati. Okei, nüüd need on niuksed. Riideasjad.
Õpetaja: Kreit read update nüüd. Read on tehtud. Nüüd oleks vaja vaadata Create Lisa uus asukoht.
Õpetaja: Asukoht Location Niukene vorm see siin.
Õpetaja: See on meil juba olemas.
Õpetaja: Komponendid Raamidegawn
Õpetaja: Saate aru taaskasutus. Nii, Ee, siin me teeme Võibolla natukene teistpidi, aga vaatame. Ee, siin on. Selles mõttes võib tulla nagu pärent. On see
Õpetaja: Location View. Tema Sees on komponent Location details input. Kus on tal laps Ja me nüüd ei teeks seda. Päris arenduses, et see väikene label ja see Boks oleks niiöelda. Ee, veel eraldi komponent. See Ei, oleks vajalik. Aga me teeme seda, sellepärast, et meil oleks.
Õpetaja: Me tahame harjutada seda asja Ka Sest päriselus on, Ee. Niiöelda niuksed, veebilehed. Kindlasti märksa. Nagu nagu raskema struktuuriga. Rohkem on taaskasutust ja asja seal tekib seda Grandchild ja veel vanemat suhet, siis meil on vaja teada kuidas seda asja manageerida.
Õpetaja: Information Floss down Okei, Let s go ee Võtame selle raamid ära.
Õpetaja: On tühi. Customer täidab selle ära. Paneb Imber ja Boom Tallinn Mustamäe Prisma. Kolm automaati. Ee, siin on lihtsalt sularaha sisse sularaha väljamaksed. Noh, See oli nagu põhimõtteliselt Niukene Eraldi komponent, onju? Nii Lõpuks valib pildi.
Õpetaja: Ee, seda siin ei saa simuleerida. Ee lisab. Ee, siis selle asukohta viiakse meid pangaautomaadid vaatesse. Võibolla teeme siia väikse. Ka. Mis ütleb, et mustamäe prisma edukalt lisatud või mida iganes saate aru mõttest,
Õpetaja: see tuli siia juurde.
Õpetaja: Read on tehtud. On Tehtud järgmisena. Okei, veel üks asi ka modal. Aa, see on nüüd special. See on veel ikka read. Read Read. Siin on Id taga. Neliteist. Kaksteist, kolmteist üksteist. Me Visuaalselt Neid ei näita kasutajale.
Õpetaja: What there there.
Õpetaja: Teil lihtsalt mõelda niimoodi, et Need on olemas seal,
Õpetaja: mis tahes. Siin võib veel rämedat infot. Siin on mingid pildid. Asjad Võiksid järgi olla veel igasugust asja mida meie, Näitame oma nagu Html Is on up to a decide. Nii kui kasuta vaid on mustamäe. Prisma tuleb. Lahti. Olete näinud niukest lahendust? Tuleb ette kastikene. Ülejäänud osad lähevad. Halliks on nii tuttav.
Õpetaja: Seda kutsutakse Modaliks.
Õpetaja: Noh, vajutad kinni. Läheb kinni.
Õpetaja: Kui see on tehtud, siis lõpuks Aa toimingutest. Me läheme ja lähme edasi. On Edit
Õpetaja: Rediti jaoks. Kasutame ikoone. Noh, midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Kui lähed iditisse. Nüüd on mõttekoht. Vaatame, mõtleme veel seda. Aa, võibolla Teeme. Natuke teist korda teistmoodi. See kord, ma mõtlen, ma tõesti mõtlen, kuidas teha Ee, muidu vanaviis on see, et taaskasutus
Õpetaja: Kuidagi tundub see tuttav.
Õpetaja: Mis on selle kompanii? Mei nimi siin.
Õpetaja: No lähme tagasi. Ma Sain niimoodi tagasi minna.
Õpetaja: Ahvatud, Ma ütlesin Packi kogemata Siin niimoodi Demo Demos ei saa vajutada. Ma võtsin selle komponendi ülesse.
Õpetaja: Pangaautomaadi. Lisaasukoht. Ee lisaasukoht. Kas siit saab jätkata Lisamisel Mis on? Komponendi nimi.
Õpetaja: Mis on Urle?
Õpetaja: Ah,
Õpetaja: ei, no lihtsalt Kaldkriips Location on see mis ma ootan, onju? Okei, lähme korra tagasi. Vaata, viu Vaatame. Nüüd korra seda Editit, et see on see sama vaade on nii
Õpetaja: Aa, mis Urliga on juhtunud natuke kuidagi teistsugune, onju?
Õpetaja: Seda, mis ma rääkisin Ee selle kohta. Selle küsimärgi juhataja lõpetab ära. Raja. Ülejäänud on parameetrid sisendid, et näita seda vaadet, aga ma annan mingit infi kaasa me Taaskasutame Location View D, et seda ka ühtlasi teha. Nagu Edit
Õpetaja: mõte on selge. Noh, ainuke asi, mis siin, peavad erinevad olema, mis on Erinev Erinev on siis see, et siin ei ole Mitte lisa uus asukoht, vaid on tekst muud asukoha infot. Siin ei ole nupp, et Lisa asukoht vaid on salvesta ja teoreetiliselt. Nad teevad erinevaid asju
Õpetaja: Nii kui editasi on ära tehtud, siis tulevad juurde.
Õpetaja: Kuidas töötab? Meil küsitakse, Näidatakse ka infot. Rohkem automaatide arv asjad. Pilt ka ja küsitakse. See on nagu miinitööriist. Kustuta,
Õpetaja: kustuta, kustuta, usuta.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui siin ühtegi linna, Mida valida ei ole, siis tuleb veel niuke teade ka. Põhimõtteliselt see funktsionaalsus on juba varasemalt kirjas.
Õpetaja: Nii küsimusi
Õpetaja: tulevad Davai Lets Go One. Nüüd vaatame seda sama asja Natukene teise nurga alt.
Õpetaja: Open on lihtsalt balsamik pank. Kus on ee? Kus on see teine projekt? Sõber?
Õpetaja: Väga Huvitav, ta ei pakkunud seda mulle.
Õpetaja: Thatcher, kuule. Mine lihtsalt siia sisse. Ole nunnu.
Õpetaja: Nii sama asi lets do It again, aga
Õpetaja: no mis meil Siis üleval siis on sisse logimine. Miks ma ei saa üleval?
Õpetaja: No saab, Ta on seal nagu üle ääres aga, saate hakkama onju,
Õpetaja: Ee, kes sõnum päriselus. Tegelikult oleks. Post oleks parem. Seda ma olen juurde õppinud.
Õpetaja: Me peame saatma. Vaata, Back end ile sõnumi
Õpetaja: nagu parool Admin ja nende kastide sisu peab minema. Jason, Sõnumina Näete seda sõnumit siin?
Õpetaja: Ee, tähendab, siin ei ole. Mis läheb sisse see läheb urli Sees läheb see raja parameetritega. Aga tema, mis ta meile vastab? Ta vastab meile Jasonina, kus on üks ja role name.
Õpetaja: Ee, võimalik error Viga, nelisada kolm respons. Body. Message vale kasutaja. Nimi või Parool Error. Kood üks, üks,
Õpetaja: üks, üks. On see, et vahet pole mis keeles See asi tuleb. Me progeme ikka ainult selle vastu, et kas näita
Õpetaja: mingit niukest asja või mitte.
Õpetaja: Nii? Logime sisse. Selle sama info olime Eelnevalt ära vastusest saadud info. Oleme ära salvestanud iseenda jaoks. Kuskil User Id
Õpetaja: Ee.
Õpetaja: Nii Liina Tedropta on sõnum Back end ile massiiv
Õpetaja: City, Id City, Name City Id City, Name City Id City name väärtustega. Selle põhjal ehitatakse see dropdown menüü. Miinus See on kõik linnad. See Ei, tule, see on hardcoditud.
Õpetaja: Okei,
Õpetaja: nüüd on, ee, juba rohkem asju vaata, et Cities tuuakse samamoodi ära. Get City sega siin Midagi ei Muutu juurde. Lihtsalt tuleb see tabel. Tabelil on, niimoodi et kett sõnum läheb teele. Gett Atm Locations City Id on null.
Õpetaja: Tema tagastab massiivi Kus on sikupilliprisma? Tondiselver. Jõeprisma kaasas on Location Id Cityname Näed Tallinn sikupilli? Prisma tallinn, sikupilli. Prisma. Sularaha sisse sularaha väljamaksed Noh, järjekord on erinev. Aga siin ei ole sõna. Sularaha. See nüüd saad. Raha See on lihtsalt näide, onju?
Õpetaja: See info tuleb siit. See siin on üks Objekt Üks rida küsimusi selle koha pealt.
Õpetaja: Jah, väga hea.
Õpetaja: Lisa asukoht.
Õpetaja: Aa, too ära. City andmed. See on juba ammu ära progetud selleks hetkeks. Too ära kõikvõimalikud. Aa, need ee, maksetüübid. Need tikpoksid Ega me neid hardcode.
Õpetaja: Tänan sularaha sisse. Sularaha välja maksed. Homme on
Õpetaja: või krüpto. Mina Ei tea, mis iganes sealt automaatselt saab teha. Näiteks lihtsalt mäng.
Õpetaja: No ja siis on, ee.
Õpetaja: Noh,
Õpetaja: aa, üks samm tagasi, Ee, tagasi tagasi saada Oo, sai kuskilt tagasi aga päris mitte õigesse kohta on ju lisaasukohta? Ee, mis ma tahtsin näha, on. Vot kui me lähme siia lisavaatele
Õpetaja: täidetud.
Õpetaja: Kui siin on olemas tallinn, siis me. Me saadame nüüd sõnumi. Postsõnum lisamine, postita.
Õpetaja: Saadame sõnumiga kaasa. Jason, ennem oli Anna mulle andmeid Jasonis ja me teeme selle visuaalseks. Nüüd on hoopis see, et korja siit info kokku. Mis on City Id üks,
Õpetaja: mis on Asukoha nimi Location Name on mustamäe. Prisma on kolm image. Data base. Kuuekümne, neljas, üks pikk, Ee, stringi joru. Ja nüüd on need transaction Type Id. Iga Taipe on üks objekt. East määratakse. Ära Vaata, kas see, teenus on seal olemas või mitte.
Õpetaja: Küsimusi Hetkel mitte.
Õpetaja: No ja Delini jõuame. Välja Vahet pole nagu
Õpetaja: nihukest asja. Hakkame meie siis progema.
Õpetaja: Ee, võibolla siis pildiseeriast midagi korraks vaadata.
Õpetaja: Tegelikult ma korra vaatan Ee Materjalidest huvi pärast.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma huvi pärast vaatan. Ee,
Õpetaja: kas ma leian ühe pildi, mis mulle tegelikult. Aa meeldib.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma Vaatan. Korra, Ma Nüüd panen huupi. Ma pole nende materjalidega tegelenud.
Õpetaja: Vaatame korra rest. Teenuseid. Action siin rest
Õpetaja: ja siis on Vaatame korra Seda Äkki on siin Juhuslikult midagi ei ole.
Õpetaja: Äkki on siin?
Õpetaja: Videod, videod, videod, videod, videod.
Õpetaja: Ahah, ahah. Võibolla siin on.
Õpetaja: Tead, ma olen nagu nii head pildid, Aga ma ei tea, mis kuradi kohas nad on.
Õpetaja: Ee, ta siis kasutab. Ee, päris seeriast. Mingeid pilte.
Õpetaja: Tähtis on Aa aru saada Mhm,
Õpetaja: Noh, ühed pildid, mis? Me Üks hetk vaatame. Läbi kolmsada, kakskümmend, kaheksa pilti.
Õpetaja: Me teeme need suht kiirelt. Ärge muretsege, ma ootan ee seda kohta.
Õpetaja: Need viimased asjad.
Õpetaja: Meie saame Back I endist andmed kokku ja tuleb Niukene Jason
Õpetaja: ja lõpus.
Õpetaja: Meie saadame sõnumi. Anna mulle andmeid.
Õpetaja: Jason tuleb vastu. Ma tahan, et saaksid sellest aru. Kust see tuleb?
Õpetaja: Meie saadab vajalikul hetkel sõnumi enda fookus puhkust ja ta annab meile Jasoni. See on nagu ainukene. Võibolla mis? Võibolla vajaks selgitamist.
Õpetaja: Ee, jah, okei.
Õpetaja: On lihtsalt mingeid küsimusi. Või siis ee, lihtsalt liigume edasi
Õpetaja: valetust. Ei ole.
Õpetaja: Noh, see oli muidu Niukene. Hea, et saab nagu ideed Enamvähem, et Mida, me tegema hakkame?
Õpetaja: Peame ehitama, onju?
Õpetaja: Okei, ee, meie võtame ette. Siis Loomulikult taski. Ee, ma selle panen to doos. Panen. Siis
Õpetaja: me juba tegime. Mul on see mingi imelik haru. Ma lähen, ee, Õpetaja peale tagasi Checkout. E,
Õpetaja: ahaa, hügieen. Ee. Mis ma peaks tegema nende nende harudega? See Jah, see ja see minu enda oma ka
Õpetaja: ära kustutama. Ja,
Õpetaja: aa, võibolla mina pole, aga minul endal on. Ma pakun see alles, sest ma. Ei Mulle ei pakkunud seda nuppu seal Ee, üleval
Õpetaja: ma olengi. Ainukene vist ei ole. Madison ka. Ja Siim
Õpetaja: Ee. Lihtsalt Selles mõttes on mõistlik need ära kustutada et, vähem
Õpetaja: ah, Noh, siin. Ei ole ka. Kui sa näed nooli, siis nende eest. Hooli, okei?
Õpetaja: Keegi Rem tegi sinna igast ägedaid asju,
Õpetaja: kuidas toitu ka ära panna, siis ta nagu ei jää nagu teil. Aa, ei ole midagi, Ära muretse.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui sa just midagi masteris seda Merchid, aga Sa Ei, peaks seda tegema.
Õpetaja: No Rem võib terve ülejäänud aja teha, kui ta juba selle otsa lahti tegi. Ära rohkem kui mitte. Palun, Ei, ma usun, et sa meelega teinud. Jah, Ee, nii kustutan mina ära ka selle Track Brunchi
Õpetaja: endal, mis on minu niiöelda minu oma, Nüüd õpetaja on jälle. See mis on meie. See jooksev seis
Õpetaja: edaspidi meeste ei tee, aga päriselus. See käiks
Õpetaja: lihtsalt See võtab nii palju mõttetut aega meil seal mingit lisandväärtust eriti ei ole, et selle kontseptsiooniga tuttavad saate seda seal töö Environment Is surmani harjutada.
Õpetaja: Nii kui meil on. Ee, see taas tehtud. Ee, siin on ka nagu midagi puudu. Kuskilt on nagu kogu aeg puudu.
Õpetaja: Panen korra lihtsalt siia lehele.
Õpetaja: Et Tunduv, Nagu näete, see error vaade läks siia.
Õpetaja: Home View Ee, Homeviews. Vaatame mis siin, üldse tegema peab Muuda koduvaadet.
Õpetaja: Muuda vaatekomponentide all Järgnevaks Navigatsiooni menüüsse peaks jääma Link, kodu, kodu. Võibolla teksti ikooni kujul. Laseme teksti kujul. Sellel võiks kuvada mingit teksti. See on mingi äge pank Ja mingi pilt. See pilt on see, kui ma veel on siin Inglismaal ja käisin niuksel muusikafestivalil nagu Pump Down. Kahel korral käisin väga Äge üritge
Õpetaja: seal. Ikka. Inimesed veits. Nagu
Õpetaja: tegid pulli ka. Ee, navigatsiooni menüüsse. Peab siis jääma mingi kodu. Ee Äge pilt, bla blabla, kustud Vajalikud Helloworld asjad. Me tegelikult tegime ära. Selle Ebavajaliku staffi. See See on nagu põhimõtteliselt. Mis tuleb nimekon Name Konventsiooni osas on Home Root. Me juba tegelikult parandasime selle ka ära.
Õpetaja: Ma pakun, et ärme hakka praegu seda taski tegema. Vaid teeme järgmise taski hulgas ka Ära lihtsalt Selle tegevuse säästame hästi natuke aega. Olete nõus,
Õpetaja: et siin on? Mis meil on. Me peame ainult selle mingi menüüsse midagi tekitama. Kodu, kuidas,
Õpetaja: No, meil ei ole nagu seda. Vaata, et see on minu pank ja. Ja seda. Vaata, onju? See on nagu nii tilulilu. Ma tõstan juba selle isegi siia ära. Et, ee, et see on nagu tehtud justkui.
Õpetaja: Aa, nüüd pangaautomaadid. Vaade, pangaautomaadid. Me teeme vaate ära
Õpetaja: ja selle Sisu on lihtsalt see, et loo Niukene pangaautomaadid. Vaade mis on aadressil Atms
Õpetaja: loommenüüsse. Ka Vastav Link nimega Pangaautomaadid Lisa juurde tekst.
Õpetaja: Ee, nii Ee, selle võime ära teha. Sellepärast järgmine taas tahab kaine Nagu sinna navigeerida peale loo kinni tahaks nagu siia, tulla et see ongi ainult selle jaoks tehtud. Põhimõtteliselt teeme need kaks korraga ära, on ju?
Õpetaja: Nüüd alustaskiks. Võtame siis ka enda nagu selle. Ee, Feb Kuus.
Õpetaja: Mis on Esimene asi, mis teeme uue aru, oleme.
Õpetaja: Võtame uue haru. Kui te olete juba selle haru pealt, kus te võtate ainult teie enda haru, Siis lihtsalt New Branch või tulete. Oot, kuidas see mul siin lokali all nõustate? Selja käest ära?
Õpetaja: Ee, et, ee. Kas ma tulen? Vajutan Siit New Branch või? Hetkel? Olen selle branche peal, vaid on New Branche peal See sama,
Õpetaja: mis ma siia kirjutan.
Õpetaja: Tere õhtust koos.
Õpetaja: Võibki, Võibolla siis selle Home View lahti võtta, et teeme siis siia ära. Nagu selle mingi kaheks. Jagame tulba kaheks. Kus on ühel pool see On mingi meie äge pank ja paremal pool Mingi suvaline pilt. Võtame netist lihtsalt. Kust iganes, onju?
Õpetaja: Aa, siin? On juba olemas see tegelikult Ta on see sama Greed aga et ülejäänud süntaksid lihtsamalt mõista,
Õpetaja: Lähme võtame uue.
Õpetaja: Lähme peal Siin Lihtsalt vajutame Copy to Clipboard ja ongi olemas,
Õpetaja: Kes tahab mingi õigesti sinna ära.
Õpetaja: Kohe näitan, kuidas mina teen. Siis teised saavad järgi teha, kes
Õpetaja: Kui ma siin nüüd räägin, et me mingeid asju teeme. Proovige vahepeal. Noh, kui ma ootan nagu näiteks teisi ja nii edasi. Kui te oskate midagi isi teha, siis on Kuuma, nagu. Minge natuke edasi. Kohe. Näete, kas ma tulen Samat teed pidi, onju?
Õpetaja: Copy.
Õpetaja: Ja ma natukene üritan, nagu leida kompromissi, selle Ee, Teised saaksid ka vaadata. Järgi, et teeme lahti Ja seesama, mis siin on.
Õpetaja: Aa, minul. Ta on selle lihtsalt asendab konteineriga.
Õpetaja: Üks, Rog, kolm, Colli.
Õpetaja: Nii juba saame. Mitu kooli meil on vaja?
Õpetaja: Kaks oli.
Õpetaja: Teeme praegu koodi ära. Siis on ju, et selle kustutame ära.
Õpetaja: Siia tuleb Aa, mis siia pidi tulema.
Õpetaja: See pidi tulema. See on mingi äge pank. Aga ärme pane kolli. Lihtsalt teksti. Tekst peaks alati olema ikka Mingi tekstielemendi sees ideaalis. Sest muidu te võtate võimaluse ära Csiga midagigi teha.
Õpetaja: Kui ta lihtsalt tekst. Kuidas ma saaksin praegult seda? No ma Selle Tv iga saaks tervet kolumit muuta. Aga äkki see ei ole ka minu soov. Et Selles mõttes ta peaks ikkagi olema mingi tekstielemendi sees. Ideaalis
Õpetaja: paneme H, üks ja see on meie.
Õpetaja: Ma paneks midagi mõistlikumat ee. Siit, Leiad kõik eesti
Õpetaja: pangaauto omad ee. Asukohad, midagi, taolist
Õpetaja: Ja siis siia alla. Peaks tulema mingisugune pilt jällegi Vaata, et me ei hakka siia pilti kohe niimoodi kõrvale panema. Vaid,
Õpetaja: meil on parem, Näha mis? Mis, Mille sees on, kui ta ei ole Ühel real on palju parem aru saada, et kui ma tõstan nagu praegu, ma saaks teha ka niimoodi, Nagu mitte midagi ei juhtu. Need vahed on ülisavi. Mis siin on. Browser sööb kõik selle Staffi nii või naa ajal ära, et Et koodi loetavus on ju tegelikult väga halb. Kui see on niimoodi,
Õpetaja: mina ka midagi aru ei saa ta seda enam sunduslikult alla ei tee. Võtan Control Setiga tagasi tarbija. Ma. Nii tahan tingimata teha.
Õpetaja: Nii Siia peab Mis asi tulema. Mingi Pilt oli kokkulepe,
Õpetaja: No kui see on pilt, mis me teeme?
Õpetaja: Image. Aga isegi mis? Seal oli mingi. Oota, ma hästi, ruttu Vaatan koera, Kus meil pilt oli Error Views. Teeme selle image I tõesti käsitsi? Aga mis tal see? Paneme sinna ise pärast juurde Img
Õpetaja: ja võtame selle variandi. Vaadake, Kus on Source alt? Aga selle halli me kustutame kindlalt ära. Ei, viitsi
Õpetaja: Balti asemele hoopis. Ee, kirjutaks. Class
Õpetaja: stiil, Glass
Õpetaja: ja seal oli Image fluid. Vist oli, onju Im hakata panema. No vaata, ta juba näeb niukest disaini.
Õpetaja: Image Fluid nüüd on ainult source
Õpetaja: Ee, no jah, Ma ei tea, otsiks netist midagi. Pank
Õpetaja: pildid ära otsima. Juba hakkab see. Oi, ma panin panka sellega Akupank.
Õpetaja: Aa, milline see oli? See Vä, Davai
Õpetaja: Ee, ma vaatan parem klõps selle peal.
Õpetaja: Ee, copy image adress, mitte link. Ja mis ma. Olen alati öelnud, kui võtad mingi Niukse asja, mis tahaks teha
Õpetaja: eraldi. Tab is tasuks korra kontrollida, et kas tõesti kogu selle asja? Kas me läheme kuhugi veebilehele nüüd või Me näeme mingit pilti. Kumb on? Tundub, et näeme pilti, et siis sul võiks justkui sobida, onju?
Õpetaja: No ma oleks võinud Gif I ka otsida, Kui me tahame odavat nagu niukest
Õpetaja: interaktiivsust ja ägesust teha. Aga, noh, kaugel me Sellega läheme, et varsti on mingid vilkuvad borderid ja Mingi taustaks, et
Õpetaja: et nagu kuskil tuleb piir tõmmata ka selles osas.
Õpetaja: No panen selle siia niimoodi ära. Lükkas ta jälle mulle üle mitme Rea sellepärast, et ta natukene arvestab seda siin
Õpetaja: mulle. Jah, siis on nii Savi.
Õpetaja: See ei ole üldse tähtis meie jaoks nagu, No ma Ütlengi mõlemad. See on väga fine. Nagu See on. See on ühe täagiga element. Siin. On mitu asja, mida vaadata et ma kohe näen, Et ma ei pea paremale vaatama. Siin on nagu bussid ja miinused. Nagu vahel, Nagu tahaks vääri ajal vahel mitte.
Õpetaja: Nii. No nüüd, kus On see tehtud, siis meil see homeview on ju? Tegelikult saab kohe testida, sest et meil ju see routing on olemas. Ee, vaade oli meil juba projektiga kaasas.
Õpetaja: Ma ütlen mina linki.
Õpetaja: Võibolla. Hästi, natuke. Ma ütlen pikseleid taga ei aja, aga võibolla Mis ajaks natukene närvi siin liiga üleval.
Õpetaja: Nüüd mina küsin. Ee, mis elemendi sees see Staff on? Mida Me, näeme?
Õpetaja: Vaadake nüüd koodi
Õpetaja: No Body sees. Ma ei näe Isegi siin sõna Bodist, et Body on kuskil indeks. Atml is, meil. Mida mis on nagu kõige kõigi kõikide ema on ju
Õpetaja: kus sees On see staff, mis ma praegu Highlight isin.
Õpetaja: Kuidas heeder? Ühes. Aga heeder Ühes. On ainult see asi ju pool. Proovi Row
Õpetaja: bingo. No Kui Ei, usu. Aa, ta niimoodi elemente ei näita. Aa, niimoodi saaks. Kui ma võtan selle suureks ja panen näiteks. Ma ei tea, ma olen. Mina olen küll niukest asja teinud. Ma olen nagu midagi üritanud saada mingit infot kätte kuskilt need, kui sa võibolla väga hästi ei saa, kui teha inspekt ja element seal. Vaata,
Õpetaja: kui vaadata, mille sees nad on, on praktiliselt sinine.
Õpetaja: Kui ma lähen. Rose, lähen. Vaadake. On siin.
Õpetaja: Kui ma lähen kooli peale lähen kooli peale, saate aru?
Õpetaja: See nüüd ei ole. Vae, Vaata, Ärge ajage see asja, et me me Pärast vaatame siin ka asju. Vaata, on ju. See on lihtsalt elements.
Õpetaja: Ahah, et siis põhimõtteliselt kogu see asi peab allapoole natuke liikuma. Olete nõus.
Õpetaja: Nii, Fine. Nüüd me võime teha reegli, et hoia. Mis Meie eesmärk on see, et lükka mind sellest baar ist natuke madalamale, onju,
Õpetaja: Aga kui me praegu selle lahenduse teeme, siis iga vaatega me tegelikult kui tahaks ühtlast joont hoida, siis on kogu aeg sama probleem ei Ole vä,
Õpetaja: et nagu. Lükka jälle mind alla ja nii edasi. Mis mõtted teil on? Nagu et mida? Mis lähenemise võiks hoopis võtta? Siin on See margin. Mida me tagajame? Mäletate? Me vaatasime marginit. Hoia mind eemale. Mis mõtted on?
Õpetaja: Saab võtta? Seda ma ütlen. Selle asja nimi Ongi Margin. Aga nüüd on küsimus, vaata, et kus me seda stiili Sest Et see see stiil saab minna ainult klaassi atribuudi sisse on ju nii
Õpetaja: on ju? Aga nüüd on küsimus, et et kui me praegult läheksime, ja teeksime, ma näitan nüüd Ära vaata selle, ma teen korra ära. See on vaatamise koht,
Õpetaja: et. Ee. Ma küsisin, kuhu sisse võiks panna. Vaata, keegi ütles. Hetkel on siin. See. Ärge tehke kaasa, On ju? Ma saaks öelda. Siin Margin
Õpetaja: nüüd. Need Marchinid saab panna tasemete kaupa ühest neljani. Ma mäletaks justkui viieni, aga okei, no on Ikka Ka
Õpetaja: nullist, nullist neljani nullist viieni. Siis Kui päris aus olla, on ju nii? See praegult on, see et hoia igalt poolt mul distantsi. Ma võin panna praegult näiteks selle margin Five, mis on kõige suurem, kui me vaatame seda lehte,
Õpetaja: hoiab eemale, on ju Aga point on nüüd see et Tegelikult, kui see roo lõppeb siin ära, siis ta lükkab ka eelmist asja. Ta lükkab paremale ja vasakule põhi lõuna Ida lääs, saate aru?
Õpetaja: Ja Ja siis on siin. Nüüd on start ja end Need on need tähed
Õpetaja: ee. Meil tegelikult oleks vaja põhimõtteliselt piisaks täiesti. Ma korra võtan selle maha, Onju, Et tekiks korra see vaade onju, et kui ma paneksin siia praegult m
Õpetaja: mis järgmine täht on tee.
Õpetaja: Margin top ja panen näiteks. Ma panen vähem, et oleks nagu selge erisus. Kaks nägite liikus natukene alla
Õpetaja: Aga point on see, et Kas me hakkame nüüd iga kord tegema seda sama asja? Okei, tegelikult sellest saaks konteinerile ka panna, kusjuures.
Õpetaja: Ee, sellepärast, et siin ei Ole ju mitte midagi muud. On ju, et ma saaksin teie järgi ka selle panna siia, Aga see lahendaks mul seda muret ära, et Ma pean uuesti uuesti seda tegema.
Õpetaja: Aga kui me nüüd saime selle süsteemi paika? Vaata, et meil on niimoodi sellise ee, sellise stiili sätega võimalik lükata asju üles alla, vasakule, paremale. Siis ma küsin nüüd uuesti. Mis mõtted on, et kuidas me võiksime teha seda niimoodi et meie, Nagu Napakad. Ei jää igal pool seda tegema.
Õpetaja: Praegu me panime põhimõtteliselt nagu siia nii öelda. On ju siis, mis mõtted on?
Õpetaja: Vaata,
Õpetaja: ei, Me tahame seda sama lähenemist kasutada, Aga point on see, et saate aru. Kui me teeme uue vaate uue konteineri siis me iga kord Oleme jälle selle sama asja küüsis. Vaata, et navigatsiooni menüü on meil, Nagu me oleme liiga lähedal, tal. Me tahame vist eemale hoida.
Õpetaja: Ühe Tühja rõhu Teevad.
Õpetaja: Mis asja aitab Sellest arendajat ei saa. Layout I. Me ei hakka tegema Breakidega nagu. Ei, aga mõtle seegi Aga okei, Ma ütlen, okei. Paneme Break I, Aga ma küsin, kuhu sa selle Break i paned.
Õpetaja: Ahaa, vot. Sa oled nagu õigel teel. Oota aga, Ee, vaata, Point on see, et vaata, et me ei taha tegelikult lükata ennast ülemisest poole allapoole või mis oleks siin mõistlik teha
Õpetaja: ülejäänsel Ribal anda,
Õpetaja: et et selles mõttes. Noh, tavaliselt ma ei ole. Ma ei ole viitsinud isegi teha, aga mõtleme nagu on ju nii, Vaata, et et kui me läheksime praegu, otsiks ülesse. Noh, siin siin. Selles elements vaates on juba näha. Vaata, et meil on siin need read, on? Ju Meil on mingi.
Õpetaja: Mingi On, et kui praegult sellele ütleks, Margin. Aa, mingi Aa Five on ju? Siis see tähendaks seda, et Ta lükkaks ju siis seda järgmist elementi endast eemale.
Õpetaja: Peaks ju nii olema. Noh, Kus meil see on?
Õpetaja: No sellepärast et siin ei ole Seda Navi, muidugi. Lähme vaatame korra. Hapuaeg,
Õpetaja: et on niimoodi. Et see, on kõik, mis on navigatsioon ja ülejäänud osa tuleb vastavalt ruuterviule on ju nii. Mis reale? Me kirjutaksime siis midagi juurde.
Õpetaja: Rida kakskümmend. No see oleks kahtlaselt. Siis nagu pakuti siin. Vaata, onju mingi, et see Võib olla see töötaks. Võibolla,
Õpetaja: aga seda me nii ei taha teha. Et kakskümmend ei ole õige kaheksa alla.
Õpetaja: Tõmba. Hea rida kaheksa alla.
Õpetaja: See Siin See on see hamburgeri menüü. Üks niiöelda mingisugune ee atribu.
Õpetaja: Kuidas ei ole õige? Ärge nüüd niimoodi hakkake jamama Vaata minuga,
Õpetaja: Jaa, rida kahe. Alla Miks sellepärast, et Ee vastab tõele? Kui ma tõmban selle asja kokku? See ongi meie.
Õpetaja: Ja kuhu me saame panna niiöelda neid. Ee, atribuute. Ainult Bigini selle niiöelda esimesse tag. I on ju nii?
Õpetaja: Atribuudid käivad alati sellest. Mitte Closing tag I Noh, siin juba Mingid piksid ja asjad Vaata siia. Tuleme siis paneme M.
Õpetaja: No, paneme kolm näiteks.
Õpetaja: Vaatame.
Õpetaja: Oi,
Õpetaja: mitte M. Kolm, Sest et see on igalt Poolt kolm. Näete, nüüd juhtuski igalt poolt kolm päh. Mis ei meeldi
Õpetaja: veits vale tulemus. Kui just ei meeldiks Niukene. Aga mulle ei meeldi
Õpetaja: M Kolm tähendab ju, et igalt poolt. Aga me tahame ainult Botom, eksole?
Õpetaja: Ehk siis. Mm. Kolm.
Õpetaja: Aa mõttes. Saite ära Mb Kolm,
Õpetaja: Kui oleks tugev. B oleks, siis oleks juba nagu see muusikaformaat, eksole?
Õpetaja: Kes jõudis endale kunagi osta mingi pulga laadse. Mingi Mp kolm mängija
Õpetaja: mõtlesid, et seda nüüd koostöö hetkel ikka mõtlesid seda? Kanan For Life Smartphone Id. Asjad tulid põmm.
Õpetaja: Mina ostsin ka mingi uhke asja ka väljas korraga ilmselt
Õpetaja: nii. Kas võib edasi liikuda, Palun, kriis.
Õpetaja: Okei, nüüd on see paigas. Noh, see ülejäänud asi on juba mingi maitse asi nagu et mingi M vi saate oma projektis teha. Vaata nii, nagu tahate. No, minule Minu ekraani pealt. Minu pikslitega tundub ja neli, mis iganes üksteist puha. See on nüüd tehtud. Aga see ei olnud taask. Vaata, taask oli tegelikult üldse midagi muud, eksole?
Õpetaja: Tuleb luua uus vaade Atms. Kuidas sai menüüd saab kuidagi kinni vanasti panna? Lihtsalt see Mingi kole asi on tekkinud.
Õpetaja: Refresh, Mis kurat joone ta on? See Inimesed, valge Vä
Õpetaja: vanasti oli külm menüü. Kuidas selle sai siit kõrvalt ära võtta? Et sa oleks nagu normaalselt näha. Okei, ee, me peame tegema uue Vaate,
Õpetaja: mis käibaus pidi olema juhuslikult. Okei, siis. Ee. Kes see kellamees on?
Õpetaja: No Davai. Väga hea, see on olemas. Nii, ee, Teeme uue vaatega. Nüüd öelge teie. Vaatame minule, palun. Ma olen uus arendaja. Mina ei oska öelda ka mütsi, kus ma alustan. Mis ma teen? No,
Õpetaja: Vius uus fail Noh, ee, ta jääb meelde. Peale seda esimest enam ei pea. Okei, mis edasi?
Õpetaja: Siin on mitmuses.
Õpetaja: Vaadake, siin on hästi Meeldiv tegelikult. Need faili nimed ja komponendid peavad olema ainsuses. Aga kui sul on kaks sõna kokku ja tervikuna, moodustab nagu ainsus on Fine, See on natukene sama ka niiöelda. Jaavas,
Õpetaja: Ee, klassi Nimed peavad alati olema ainsuses. Miks, Sest me saame seda objekte teha,
Õpetaja: kui sul on Mingisugune asi mitmuses.
Õpetaja: Oota, mõtleme korra, kui ma teen. Student nagu, ee. Klassi.
Õpetaja: Nii kui ma nüüd teen sellest listi ehk massiivi,
Õpetaja: kus mul Saab olla palju keeran tagasi. Kui ma teen ühest I, siis võiks olla muutuja nimi,
Õpetaja: student. Nii Kui ma teen mingisuguse nimekirja või massiivi, Kus on võib neid palju olla. Mis võiks selle muuta, Nimi Olla
Õpetaja: Ei mingilist, Ei, ei, students.
Õpetaja: Miks list? Või siis
Õpetaja: Sellepärast Java on Tüübikindel nagu ma näen seda tüüpi. Igal juhul, kui ma tahan, et mis tüüpi objektiga on tegemist? List on tüüp,
Õpetaja: Mul ei ole vaja, See ei anna mulle mitte midagi juurde See selle kohta ütleks. Ma olen näinud projekte, kus niimoodi kasutatakse. Mõnes kohas on see põhjendatud. Võibolla Kui see on mingi niukene skripti laadne asi. Vaata. Ja seal ei ole nagu tüüpe. Siis sa tahad nagu muuta nimeks, kui sa võid Sinna, mida iganes külge panna. Põhimõtteliselt
Õpetaja: let students. No sealt ka mitmes niimoodi panna. No tegelikult väga palju. Põhjendusi ei ole. Millal listi panna?
Õpetaja: Se sellepärast, et sa teed oma koodi ju pikemaks. Iga Jumala koht, kus sa nüüd seda muutujat kasutad, Nimetad jälle. Ee, t Neli tähte juures
Õpetaja: pole vaja. Need isegi kipuvad juba soojaks minema. Üleüldiselt üldiselt on üldse. Niuke printsiip. Rogemises
Õpetaja: Kui pääseb ilma ja otseselt ei ole vaja, Siis ei ole vaja.
Õpetaja: See ei tähenda muidugi eranditult, et kuskil võiks olla mingis mingisuguses kontekstis. Mingeid ekstra abirattaid. Vaata, mis võiks mõelda, et, Noh, võib ka olla mitte. Ma kutsutan abiratasteks neid. Vaata midagi, mis aitab kuidagi paremini aru saada või mida iganes, onju, et see on Niukene asi. Aga list ei ole mõtet. Jaavas kindlasti mitte. Me hoiame muutuja nimesid nii lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: Kui me saame kasutada klassi nime muutaja nimena Siis me teeme seda.
Õpetaja: Kui on kaks objekti. Vaata ja kaks muutujat, siis ei saa juba. Vaata, see on jama. Aga, ee, Iga kord, Kui meil on mingisugune muutuja, me hoiame seda niivõrd lihtsaks ja iga kord. Meie vastus on klassis või tüübis,
Õpetaja: Kui see on student klass.
Õpetaja: Siis see on student uute nimi. Kui see on list
Õpetaja: student objektidest, siis see oli lihtsalt Students
Õpetaja: Ongi kõik. Aga ärge unustage klassi nimi, Ma üritangi jõuda. Klassi nimi peab olema sada protsenti ainsusest. Sest kui klassi nimi oleks tudents, nii kui sa teed sellest ühe objekti, mis oleks selle muutuja nimi,
Õpetaja: kui sa peegeldaks ainult klassi nime students. Kui sa koodis kuskil loeksid, students, siis sa mõtled automaatselt, et siin on neid mitu põmm. Vale Fine muutuja nime paneme lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: Aga see oleks nii tobe. See oleks nii, Tove, vaata. Ja nüüd ma küsin veel Parem, kui sa teed listiobjektidest students,
Õpetaja: siis kuidas siis sa siis juba hakkab tulema? Studentslist,
Õpetaja: Sest muud moodi enam ei saa, sest otsa ei Pane vaata enam. See ei ole enam nagu By the way see. Ei ole minu välja mõeldud reeglid need. On jaava konventsioonid nagu, et Nagu selles mõttes isegi aruta neid, et nagu, miks võiks. Vaata sellepärast, et Nii on. No see on tava
Õpetaja: Klassi nimi on Ainsus Ees. Klassi nimi algab suure tähega.
Õpetaja: Muutuja Nimi algab väikse tähega. Need on paigas. Neid ei saa eirata.
Õpetaja: Tehniliselt nad võivad töötada, But you don T to It.
Õpetaja: Saad kohe vastu näppe küsimus.
Õpetaja: Lugesin. Vaatasin seda videot. Siis mul jäi kuidagi meelde, et see, kui meil on massiiv sees, Siis tegelikult objekt on ikkagi nagu üks objekt. Kuigi seal võib olla see massiiv, Kus on tegelikult. Ee. Kas ma siis ikkagi annan objekti Nimeks, kuigi ta on üks objekt. Mis? Sest, et seal on massiiv sees?
Õpetaja: Ei, vaata massiivi. Sees on objekt.
Õpetaja: Vaata, mi selles mõttes Vaata, Siin on võibolla erinev olukord. Ma. Ma toon näite. Näiteks ma toon Näitab.
Õpetaja: Ee, oletame. Meil on mingi niukene objekt Ee, mingisugune Aa,
Õpetaja: no Mingi kontode raport on ju? Niuke, objekt on, oletame. Oletame, et seal on üks väli nagu, Aa,
Õpetaja: Nagu et mingisugust kuupäevade vahemik, meil on Kaks välja, tõenäosus.
Õpetaja: Nii, kaks välja. Said From they Two Näiteks. Seal nüüd. Tuleb Väli vaata. Näiteks accounts Ja on list tüüpi ee. Objekt Kus sees võivad olla Account? Objektid on ju nii? Siin on nagu see. Vaata, et see klassi enda nimi siis saaks olla sel juhul Mingi Accounts report. Aga täna Ainsuses
Õpetaja: ja seal sees võib olla selline muutuja, on ju? Aga selles mõttes, et kui meil on mistahes list,
Õpetaja: Siis see Mitmus, siis. Ee, siis selle muutuja nimi on lihtsalt see objekt, mis seal tüübis on? Ära määratud? Lihtsalt on ju niimoodi? Lihtsalt On nagu parem, kui mis seal taustal toimetab.
Õpetaja: Vanadest aegadest. List on mugav objekt, kus on mõnusad meetodid nagu Ad ja muu ja ja Find. Ja mida iganes. Igast asju on seal ja nii edasi. Nii Ee, et kui meil on mingi list ee mingisugustest objektidest, siis me Lihtsalt vaatame, mis objektidest,
Õpetaja: kui see on account. Kui see on student, Kui see on person, Kui see on order,
Õpetaja: siis on mi, siis on täpselt selle muutuja nimi Selle klassi tüüp Järjest lõpus
Õpetaja: Ainuke olukord on see Kuidas me sellest lihtsusest läheme mööda on see, kui meil on Kaks listi samadest objektidest.
Õpetaja: Näiteks on all accounts ja accounts to delete.
Õpetaja: Kui meil on Samas selles coopis on kaks listi sellest samast.
Õpetaja: Noh, samad list Id, siis me nagu ei saa mõlemale panna Lihtsalt accountsent. I Maal vaid on, et ma ei tea, mingi read.
Õpetaja: Ee, Kas on vastus su küsimusele?
Õpetaja: Jah, aga me jõuame. Aga me. Sest et meil ei ole koodi ees. Meil oli silme ees koodi ma Praegu palusin teil ka enda nagu oma Peas. Ette kujutada asju, millega te veel ei ole kogemust. Vaata, aga okei, see selleks
Õpetaja: ee, mis See vaade oli. Mis selle nimi oli üldse? Atms.
Õpetaja: Viuh, Nüüd see siin on ka tegelikult. Ee, voetava
Õpetaja: see See on tava, et vaatekomponendid saavad selle view lõpu sinna. Tehniliselt pane siin mida iganes.
Õpetaja: Ma võin panna Sõna otseses mõttes, mida iga mees and it works,
Õpetaja: aga thats Not how we do it. Kokkulepe on niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Ee, okei, template osas. Ee, veel, ma ei taha teha. Ma teen pärast meie elu natukene lihtsamaks. Mul ei ole hetkel veel soovi.
Õpetaja: Jah, ei, vahe on Siis
Õpetaja: kirja viis. Üks on aa uus me uus lähenemine kuidas koodi kirjutada Ja kuidas asju teha teine on vanem. Lähenemine on lihtsalt beginner. Friendly
Õpetaja: Composition Api ei ole. Mida on, Mis ta peamiselt lahendab, on ta lahendab, lahendab selle mure ära, et kuidas saaks funktsionaalsust taaskasutada erinevates kohtades?
Õpetaja: Ee, see lihtsalt ei ole nagu nii lihtne, aga ma ütlen, et seal ei ole. See ei ole hea. Süntaks on tegelikult minu meelest keerulisem. Veelgi hullem on see, et seal on veelgi rohkem abstraktsiooni
Õpetaja: kirjutad, Mingisugused read taustal toimuvad mingit tegevused automaatselt ära. Mida selle puhul me peame ise progema. Me ei taha seda. Te peate Mõistma
Õpetaja: peate. Mõistma, Seda Flow asja. Aa, ma sain. Aa, Okei, Üks, Meil olid kokkulepped, mäletad? Üks kokkulepe oli selline, meil, et. Ee. Kui te palute oma, Kellel see sugulane oli? Vaata või terve perepeaga oli mingi arendajad.
Õpetaja: Kui te näitate õppeprojekti kellelegi, siis te selgitate ka, et see on õppeprojekt, Siin on taotlikud asjad
Õpetaja: nii nagu nad on.
Õpetaja: Mitte sellepärast. Vaata sellepärast, et. Ee, need inimesed, kes Anna, kes nagu neid soovitusi jagavad, ma Sain just eelmine grupp oli niimoodi. Üks inimene tuli minu eest vabandama. Ütles, et. Kuule, ma vabandan ette ära. Juba, et. Ee, ma nüüd rääkisin.
Õpetaja: Ee, jah. Mingi eesti ülitegijale vennale. Üks asutajatest ka, et käis, näitas oma mingi õppeprojekti Koodi. Vaata ja siis see inimene kirjutas
Õpetaja: Bcs I põhimõtteliselt nagu et te kasutate mingeid asju. Mi, millest? Nagu maailm on natuke. Mööda läinud.
Õpetaja: No minu challenge on see. Vaata ka, et Vahel peab olema ratsionaalne ka see, et ei ole mõistlikum kõige uuemaid asju õpetada sellepärast. Et, neid ei ole lihtne õpetada
Õpetaja: Ei ole mul, On kolm nädalat aega, et teid siin õpetada. Front Back pluss Andmebaasid. Palun väga, tule klassi ette.
Õpetaja: Aa, tule. Õpeta, et. Ee, kui te näitate midagi, siis te ütlete ka, et et siin on täpselt kõik asjad. Nii
Õpetaja: Sellepärast nii on hea õpetada teile. Keegi võiks öelda, vaata, Et miks, Miks Options Api?
Õpetaja: No sellepärast, et nagu Never Ever Ei, oleks te valmis selleks et õppida nagu seda raskemat stiili seal on plussid. Aga ma ütlen ka seal hästi. Palju abstraktsiooni Mulle ei meeldi tookord Ma ütlesin Davai, et ma mõtlen, nagu võta kasutusele, aga täna Ma tean, et
Õpetaja: ma kahe ütleme niimoodi, et kolmest soovitusest üks soovitus oli, mis? Ma võtsin, Nagu kuulda, et Davai teen ära, onju ee Ja ma ütlesin, muidugi Teen kõik ära, kui vaja. Aga Tegelt täna ma saan aru
Õpetaja: ma Ei, saa, sa lihtsalt. Ma ei saa. See On nagu nii võimatu, nagu et kõike Ei, saa.
Õpetaja: Ee, ta ei hakkagi muidu mitte midagi mõistma
Õpetaja: nii. Selle script i Me. Tõstame siia alla poole skoobi. Lihtsalt kustutame ära.
Õpetaja: Ja see, et, ee, see template ei hakkaks siin ee vinguma. Teeme ajutiselt lihtsalt ühe Divi lihtsalt
Õpetaja: I Love Optimalising. Nii,
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd jätamegi meelde, et iga kord, kui me teeme uue vaate, mis on meie kõige esimene samm, mis on kõige Esimene teie samm.
Õpetaja: Mis te siis teete?
Õpetaja: Vara?
Õpetaja: Aga teeme seda kohe ka.
Õpetaja: Ah? Nihukene View Fail on olemas.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd, mis nüüd on Järgmine samm.
Õpetaja: Noh, see on juba parem. Ta on mis? Keha
Õpetaja: konteiner? Jah, noh, ühelgi. Lihtsalt üks tehnoloogia nime. Siis olen nõus.
Õpetaja: Puts, träp,
Õpetaja: Vot noh, midagi niukest asja. See on, et, ee, ma ütlen ka, Rääkisin siin vahetunnis ka. Vaata, et mõned, meeskonnad vanasti lihtsalt mõtlesid, et Nad tegelevad selle tiluliluga Kõik, hiljem, et nagu paika panna, et lihtsalt tegid tuimad, ülikoledad kastikesed, nagu me tegime seda front, nagu me tegime Seda üheksakümnendate panka, mäletate?
Õpetaja: Noh, mingi põhimõtteliselt panid niimoodi tuimalt. Vaata aga, teed seal lõpus kolm korda Võtab. Rohkem aega, et seda korda teha. Kui lihtsalt korra tulla, teha see copywaste ära ja ongi kõik.
Õpetaja: Sa oled Tv asemel olekski võinud lihtsalt panna.
Õpetaja: Ee, võib korra vaadata. Ka. Aa ütleme niimoodi, et praegult jätame etteruttavalt lihtsalt kaks kolumnit siia.
Õpetaja: Ee, ja siis.
Õpetaja: Ahaa. Võib olla tegelikult ikkagi teeme nii, nagu siin taaskis on? Ei, tegelikult. See on ka halb asi. Vaata, ma olen selles ka sugeda saanud. Päris Production i elus. Ma teen mingisugust projekti ja taaski.
Õpetaja: Ee, kus Ma tean, et tuleb mingi jätku taask ja ma tean, et see tuleb ka tegelikult mulle. Vaata, et see on nagu See on sõltuvus. Üks asi tuleb enne ära teha. Siis saab alles järgmise asja teha, kuna Noh, ta tarbib nagu seda või nii, ja Mul oli vahel nagu niuke kiusatus, Nagu ma juba teadsin. Mis? Nagu ette rutates, Nagu mida? Võibolla võiks juba Noh, mis tuleb niikuinii lõppkokkuvõttes,
Õpetaja: Ja siis ma sain ikkagi sugeda. Vaata sellest, et. Okei, Rain. Ma tean, et see tuleb. Ette ja See on ja nii, ja kõik on väga tore, aga lihtsalt. Sa pead tegema neid asju, mis on taaskis kirjeldatud, et seal on nagu see meie Muidugi natukene mängime, onju?
Õpetaja: Me oleme õpilased siin. Aa, et idee järgi. Ma tahtsin juba kohe ette panna, et mitu kolumnit ja Nii, edasi. Aga me keskendume ikkagi Praegusel hetkel, et me saame mingi niukse visuaali.
Õpetaja: Nii pangaautomaadid. Siia tuleb. Ee, ei, tule siia Lihtsalt Column, vaid
Õpetaja: kolumni. Sisse teksti ei pane, vaid on.
Õpetaja: Teeme mingi hüks. Mida iganes, onju, et hoiame siis H. Ühte Igal pool automaadid. Nii
Õpetaja: nüüd me teeme seda, mida ütles. Ee, Triin vist oli ennem siin. Mainis, mis me teeme. Triin
Õpetaja: indeksisse. Pange töö juba ees. Ärge oodake mind, aga minu vaadet?
Õpetaja: Mingi Tehke ära seal. Ee, ee. Mis seal on vaja teha?
Õpetaja: Mis see urm?
Õpetaja: Ee, mina olen siis ka Ruuteri indeksis. Ee,
Õpetaja: mida see asi siin aitab teha. Kuidas nüüd, kuidas seal teha? Kõige lihtsam on see, et võtad selle kõige alumise
Õpetaja: koos selle komaga. Vaata siis see kunagi ei unune. Ja tulete niimoodi reavahetusega? Küblike mida. See asi mõjutab
Õpetaja: kuidas? See asi töötab
Õpetaja: see? On siis see koht kus, on ära defineeritud et, kui Ee, tuleb sisse Sõnum Mingi rajaga. Siis vaatame, mida on vaja näidata.
Õpetaja: Selle tuleb ilusti siit ära kustutada. Contra Kaksisv, näiteks, mis on mis Ma kirjutan, kuidas ma kirjutan.
Õpetaja: Ja. Aga mis ma. Mis on need tähed, mis ma võiks trükkida? No võib ka nii. Mina paneks lihtsalt Uute tähtede kv. Mida rohkem on Views E.
Õpetaja: Noh, kas te näete neid siniseid osasid? Vaata, et kuidas ta Narrow Downi teeb, nagu
Õpetaja: ma Teen alati niimoodi. Enamus kohtades, kui on failid. Nad mängivad kokku.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd puhtalt. Aa, see võiks töötada.
Õpetaja: No kui siin minna nüüd käsitsi Ee, minna ja proovima. See on vaatamise koht ka niikuinii. Teeme kohe koodi edasi. Kui ma panen Atm, S, siis see tuleb ette. Küll
Õpetaja: Atm S.
Õpetaja: Nii, aga taskis on hoopis midagi muud. Taskis Öeldakse, et peaks olema siin üleval lingid, kodu ja pangaautomaadid,
Õpetaja: kus me neid asju Näpime ja käp. Ime.
Õpetaja: Nav baaris, kus nav baar elab?
Õpetaja: Upwise also, mida ka soovitan vaikselt hakata Mõtlema. Keyboard. Iga Ma panen meelega praegu Close all. Tabs
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt see on nagu vaatamise koht. Aga võib ka kontrol Control F on niimoodi. Mis? Otsib selle faili sees, kus me Hetkel oleme Ma korra teen lahti. Näiteks siit. Control F otsib siit faili seest.
Õpetaja: Control Shift F otsib üle projekti.
Õpetaja: Siis Muidugi peab järgima. Ta vahel paneb direktori, peale, et et ei kogu projekti ja nii edasi, onju?
Õpetaja: Nüüd, Aa, kui see panna uuesti edasi. Aa, noh Finefiles,
Õpetaja: Ma juba panin Control shift Find in files. Aga vaadake, kui te vajutate Control Shift n
Õpetaja: siis ta otsib faili nimesid.
Õpetaja: Kui te päevast päeva Tegelete kuskil projektis. Te tegelikult juba teate. Enamvähem neid faili nimesid. Teil on seal palju Katalooge Palju faile, et asju üles otsida. Ma Kasutan seda all the Time Nagu Kui mul oleks vaja praegu teha lahti. Mis värmise ma pidin tegema üldse?
Õpetaja: Vaata, kus kohas ta oli. Jah, puhas on ju? Panete neid suuri tähti samamoodi? Kui paneks A v
Õpetaja: Av Enter olemas Control shift n a
Õpetaja: Olemas ei peagi nagu hiirega minema möllama.
Õpetaja: Noh, siin niikuinii tahame hiirega möllata, et selles mõttes midagi ei säästnud. Aga te ei pea otsima nagu Projektis, kus on Juba mingi viiskümmend. Pluss faili ja kataloogi, et te ei pea otsima nagu niimoodi. Noh, te kui te saate, võtate selle harjumuse, eks, et Te kolistate neid faile, Millega te tegelete? Niimoodi te jõute kümme korda kiiremini
Õpetaja: pane. Kas. Paar tähte vaata? Juba tuleb mingisugused Asjad ja küll Leiad
Õpetaja: nüüd. Kus on meil ee koha? Kus kohas on meil siis need lingid? Mis ridadest räägime?
Õpetaja: Neliteist. Viisteist. Hetkel on meil siin need kodu. Ee, on niiöelda. Kodus on Lingi nimi. See on siis hetkel meil
Õpetaja: home. Aga meil on task is Kodu Meie süsteemis on eestikeelsus.
Õpetaja: Kodu on kodu.
Õpetaja: Kus on kodukodu? Kus on kodu? Kus on kodukoht?
Õpetaja: Teate küll, mis filmis ta on?
Õpetaja: Tubli on.
Õpetaja: Vaatasin kunagi oma seitsme aastase plikaga. Selle eest hakkas muutma.
Õpetaja: Ühesõnaga, nüüd on see süsteem. Hetkel on see About siin. Selle Me saadame kohe pensionile, aga me saame seda taaskasutada. Hetkel peaks meil olema kodu Ja
Õpetaja: palun pangaautomaadid,
Õpetaja: pangaautomaadid ja rada on.
Õpetaja: Vaatame
Õpetaja: nii, et selle peame ka panema, kui on keerukamad Rajad Kui on keerukamad rajad, siis Minu soovitus on, et pigem nagu copy based ida kuskilt siit.
Õpetaja: Ärge tehke vigu. Vaata, tulge lihtsalt, siia. Aga, noh, väga palju keerulisust ei ole. Nagu, va? Noh, ütleme niimoodi, et täna ma teeksin natukene ee, paremini.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma ei jaksa siin midagi. Ma peaks igalt poolt mingi miljon muudatust tegema. Kui ma tahan mingit kõige väiksemat muudatust teha, et ma, nagu ei viitsiks, aga
Õpetaja: olenemissüsteem on? Kui ma näitan oma klassiraha projekti, siis näete urle seal ja saate snit I, kuidas võibolla oma töödes ee tiimiprojektides pigem paremini teha, Siin on nii väiksed, funktsionaalsed, et siin need on. Fine Siin ma ei oskakski midagi muud, aga mu mõte on see, et nad võivad olla ikkagi natuke pikemad ka, kui need siin praegu.
Õpetaja: Nii, Any how. Nüüd see on muudetud. No nüüd saab proovida. Nüüd On ju link olemas. Kodu, pangaautomaadid, kodu, pangaautomaadid. Mis see kisu meeldib, On hea meel et me valisime selle
Õpetaja: venna.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: Ee. Vaatab vahepeal taaski loo uus Vaatekomponent tehtud menüüsse ka. Vastav Link. Pangaautomaadid Lisa juurde. Tekstpanga, automaadid. Kas meil. On midagi enam teha?
Õpetaja: Tõesti Testisime juba nii, et ma panen Selle Dun I.
Õpetaja: Ma panen selle Done I. Kui see nüüd on. Done, mis me nüüd teeme, on mitu
Õpetaja: pausi teeme Väga hästi, aga Enne kui pausil läheme, äkki maja põleb maha.
Õpetaja: Teeme ikka kommit I ära, onju?
Õpetaja: No siin võib panna. Siis paneme siis veb kuus compliet, Näiteks ja siin Se See läheb ainult niimoodi nende peale
Õpetaja: teeme.
Õpetaja: Ja ärme push Ige. Isegi teeme ka lihtsalt komitee.
Õpetaja: Me Ei, hakka seda ootama Sellepärast, mis me nüüd teeme. Me teeme teistmoodi. Me ei hakka pulbreiku hästi tegema. Pulregveste jaoks oleks vaja see haru välja. Push Ida on? Ju.
Õpetaja: Ee, aga me ei hakka seda isegi Push ima. Meil oleks vähem tööd. Lihtsalt me näitasime. Me vaatasime ära, kuidas see Bull Request käis ja te võite seda teha ka. Tegelikult, kui te hakkate tiimiprojekte, tegema, miks mitte keegi teeb Pull Requesti ja siis keegi vaatab üle. Me räägime need reeglid täpsemalt üle kuidas mida vaadata ja teha niikuinii,
Õpetaja: aga isegi siis tegelikult ei keela, et me teeme nüüd niimoodi, et me merch ime selle arenduse haaru Masterisse. Seda te peate ikka tegema. See tähendab, seda. Me Teeme nüüd mitte läbi pilve, vaid me Teeme hoopis läbi arvuti.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd, mis selleks vaja on, on see, et on vaja saada aru Merchimise suunast
Õpetaja: kittis kõik asjad on Aa Pull, mis puudutab muudatusi.
Õpetaja: Muudatuste viimine ühest kohast teise.
Õpetaja: Et Me peame saama aru seda. Esiteks meil on kõik ära, kui mitu tükki kenasti Me peame olema selle haru peal,
Õpetaja: kuhu me soovime muudatusi, et kui ma tulen praegu, et me oleme õpetaja Feb kuus, kui ma tulen Selle õpetaja peale.
Õpetaja: Kui ma tulen siia, siis Mis ta siin ütleb, Merch?
Õpetaja: Pühendada.
Õpetaja: Jah, okei, ühendada küll. Või Vii töö üle, aga vaatame korra seda järjekorda. Merch. Õpetaja. Intu õpetaja Feb. Kuus pole suund, Sest et lükata ei saa,
Õpetaja: Kui tuleb mingid konfliktid ja asjad, sa pead need lahendama, kui Noh, tal midagi ei meeldi.
Õpetaja: Ja see kogu see süsteem on tegelikult selles mõttes nagu full nii nagu sa tõmbad ee, muudatusi ka sisse
Õpetaja: kui ongi. Vaata, pastar on edasi läinud. Te teete pulli. Ju. Too mulle muudatused. Me peame lihtsalt vahetama Haru,
Õpetaja: lähme haarule Checkout. Oi, ja oota, korras. Oli, Ee, kohe räägin seda ka. Ee, mm,
Õpetaja: ee, Mitte Master, vaid Rem, Mitte Masterweid.
Õpetaja: Prem.
Õpetaja: Ei, ei, ei, Ei, minul jah. Vaata aga ma mõtlen teil
Õpetaja: Ja Ja ma rääkisin remmist korra. Vaata, ma tegin nalja. Kuule, ja ma tean, mis sa ikka tegid? Ee, ühesõnaga me Masteri peale on vaja minna. Aga oma master.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd, kui vaatate seda, et see on ka Niukene koht, Kus ma ütlen, et iga kord, iga kord, kui te hakkate Merchima ja jõuate hiirega siia, peale, siis te lasete hiirest käpad lahti ja Ei, vajuta ja loete. Noh, selle võib natuke eest ära võtta, et teksti lugeda. Ja te loete rahulikult selle läbi.
Õpetaja: Kas see on see, Mida te tahate teha, sest et seda tagasi keerata on tüütu. Vaata, kui ta suudab selle ära teha ja nii edasi. Merch Feb Kuus Into Master on kind loeks, aga Productionist ja niimoodi teha. Niikuinii ei saa. Sest Masteris ei saa Merch Ida,
Õpetaja: aga siin me soovime, et Oma töödes te teete. Vaata, et teil on ju tiimi. Teil teel tiimis hakkab ikkagi olema see
Õpetaja: tiimis teil Ei, ole? Nagu ee, seda, et on näiteks Marten ja Martin Feb. Mingi kuus või mida iganes. Teil hakkab olema päriselt master. Ja omanimeline haaru on siis haaru,
Õpetaja: niimoodi Hakkab teil olema valdavalt nagu taskenumbrit panna, et siis hakkab olema kogu aeg see, et kui Artur teeb tiimi töös oma tüki ära, mis ta teeb. Kui töö on tehtud, siis ta mörsib selle Masterisse.
Õpetaja: Mis ta peale seda teeb, on. Koputab oma tiimiliikmetel õla peale ja ütleb, Et, ee. Masterson tehtud töötavad. Ahah, väga tore. Commitivad oma töö oma arenduse harus ära.
Õpetaja: Mis nad siis teevad? Nad merchivad master i enda arenduse haarusse, siis mis Artur tegi, On minul ka olemas.
Õpetaja: Kui tuleb mingi väike konflikt, et sina ka just oled kommittind ja teinud siin Mingisugust sama faili, mida Artur näiteks tegi? Sa saad selle konflikti üli lihtsalt ära lahendada. Aga mingi seda ei ole. Ja lõpus, kui sina, Tahad Merch. Ida, vaata enda tööd tagasi Masterisse. Siis ta juba kõik on tiktop. Vaata, tal ei ole mingit probleeme
Õpetaja: ja siis ongi see Vaata, kuidas see tuleb välja. Kui sina tahaksid hakata Merchima oma tööd Masterisse. Ta ütleb, et on konflikt. Konflikt on, et midagi ei sobi, Vaata, on ju siis tegelik Protsess on ikkagi niimoodi. Vaata, sa peaksid kõigepealt selle Masteri endale tõmbama. Sisse
Õpetaja: Selle konflikti ära lahendamine kõik toimib Ee, korrektne. Midagi katki ei läinud.
Õpetaja: Ikka Mörtsuse käigus võib asju katki minna, et noh, üks väike viga, üks pisikene viga ja läheb katki. Kui sina mörtsid enda töö masterisse ja lahendad konflikti valesti ära, siis Master on katki.
Õpetaja: Kui aga see on, see et on jahtunud mingit uut tööd juurde ja kahe faili vahel on konflikt, on ju Aga sina nagu oma arenduse arust, sa möltsid selle, Master I, kui sa, nüüd siin midagi selles protsessis valesti teed, siis on ainult sinu arenduseharu katki.
Õpetaja: Vaata, et sa te saate rohkem seda kogemust, kui asi läheb praktiliseks.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui te teete tiimitöid,
Õpetaja: et ee, kogu aeg. Te peate tegema niimoodi et võimaluse korral eriti kui nad olete nii uued, ka Vaata, ee, lahendamine on tüütu. Palun hoidke Master Joonel. Ärge hakake tegema mingi lokal arendust.
Õpetaja: Hullu Panete toodate nagu Koodi nagu mingid metslased ja Master on nagu eelmisest ee aastas seal, et tegime projekti ja lisasime kitte. Ja seal seisab. On ju,
Õpetaja: et Master peab kogu aeg minema. See on teie arendus, Mille kallal te töö see on. Teie projekt,
Õpetaja: Master on see, mis peab edasi liikuma Kogu aeg paus läks ülevaate veits, et.
Õpetaja: Aga ma ei jõudnudki vajutada. Vaata, ma ütles õpetaja veepiltu.
Õpetaja: Nii vaatame, kui ma ära merchin. Kas ta mulle seda pakub? Vaadake, Mis ta all pakub, Mis ta pakub vaasakas nurgas
Õpetaja: Jaa, noh, sellepärast, et kui sa töömörtsisad endale masterisse ära, onju, mis sa siis selle Arvuka enam. Teed.
Õpetaja: No Kui ma panen nagu kuus, siis ta seda teebki. Kui mul oleks praegult pilves Haru musicalt push itud, siis ta Pakuks nüüd siin paremal pool.
Õpetaja: Sa teed nagu. Noh, kui ta on sul siin, ta. On sul seal, Ta on sul Masteris olemas, Lükka oma Master pilve. Ja nüüd ongi mis sul üle. Miks ta näitab nüüd? Minul Masteril näitab seda rohelist noolekest. Ee, sellepärast, et siin on Aga pilves ju ei ole.
Õpetaja: Aga kui sa tegid selle? Kui sa näed noolt, siis kannad oma järgi. Hoolt, on ju Ja Action pätu
Õpetaja: Push, ime ära lihtsalt. Ja, noh, asi on. Ta on nii nüüd küll pausi teha.
Õpetaja: Kas ma panen julgen panna rekordi pausi? Ka Ee Ma pigem seda ei seletaks. Laseks seda Ee, selgitada. Aa, Cloud Il. Sest et ta teeb niukse väikse skeemi, Arvatavasti kus on see tuleb Hästi, kiirelt välja.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui me jäime. Me saime selle Feb kuuega vist ühele, poole, on ju
Õpetaja: No nüüd läheb lõpuks põnevamaks. Aa, Feb, Seitse on järgmine.
Õpetaja: Vaata, mis tegema peab. Räägitakse andmebaasi mudelist.
Õpetaja: Ee, kuidas andmebaasi mudelid õudselt tahaks lugeda et Nagu need on read, aga need ei ole siin read. Need on hoopis
Õpetaja: veeru nimel.
Õpetaja: Meil on tabel nimega User ja tabel nimega Role. Meist ei pääse üle ega ümber et vaadata ka seda asja.
Õpetaja: Tabelid.
Õpetaja: Nii, meil on tabel roll ja user.
Õpetaja: Kui ma panen selle korra siia kõrvale, me keskendume ainult nendele Kahele tabelile, Mis meil siin on,
Õpetaja: on roll.
Õpetaja: Unroil on. Vaadake, veerud Id. Ja Name on veerud Id ja name
Õpetaja: niimoodi. On Kuidas relatsioonilise andmebaasi graafiliselt kujutatakse, et saaks aru, kuidas asjad nagu on omavahel. Ee seotud. Natuke väiksemaks teha. Staatus on seal ka. Veel No, väevalve näoga Vahet pole, ee. Peaasi, et nagu näete, enam vähem midagigi, siis usertabelis. Noh, tee vaadake siia. Mina loen siit
Õpetaja: Id Roll Id username Password Status on nii
Õpetaja: peegeldab seda. Vaatame nüüd, kuidas need asjad käivad. Neid saab kohe suuremaks. Uumendada. Sequence Counter algab, aga see ei ole esimene väärtus, vaid ütleme. Algseis on null.
Õpetaja: Kui tekib üks uus rida juurde näiteks, rol tuleb juurde. Admin,
Õpetaja: siis kuidas see töötab, et süsteem võtab tuimalt järgmise Counter I Väärtuse, Aga teeb talle ennem pluss pluss. Pluss pluss tähendab lihtsalt et väärtus muutub ühe võrra suuremaks kogemises, on see Tavaliselt niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Üks tuleb siia. Üks on saadaval, kui siia tuleb. Näiteks juurde. Mis siin. Ennem üldse oli?
Õpetaja: Paul Admin
Õpetaja: Customer. Customer ei ole Kostumeeri vaid. On klient. Seda samamoodi, et sedasi ära salvestata. Võetakse, et mis on siin. See number riidetakse tal kõigepealt üks juurde saadakse kaks Ja see läheb siia küsimusi kohta.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui mina tahan kasutajat, kasutaja, paneb näiteks Admin Password. Üks, kaks, kolm. Status on A Nagu active. Näiteks, ee, siis tema oma
Õpetaja: ma veel ei saa. See väli on täitmata
Õpetaja: siin. Nüüd on Forengi. Kui selle asja nimi on Pk Primerigi, Noh, siin. On ka Pk. Näete, juures on see nool Natukene segab,
Õpetaja: aga te näete, mis? Seal all on forengi.
Õpetaja: Mis asi on tegelikult siis numbriline väärtus, mida ei genereerita, vaid seda täidetakse. Mis viitab siis?
Õpetaja: Noh, anna nüüd. Miks ma ei saa siia kirjutada, kus on vä
Õpetaja: Kirjutada saan ju. Ma tahan lihtsalt klikkida. Näed, on see role? Tabeli viide on ja role tabelile veerule Id.
Õpetaja: Kui Admin tahab päriselt ka olla See ainult kasutajanimi, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, siin saaks olla. Noh,
Õpetaja: ma ei tea meie mingi adin näiteks. Ma ei taha, et ta oleks Adin Adin.
Õpetaja: See nimi ei tee teda adminiks, vaid talle tuleb roll külge panna. Nüüd mina küsin teie käest. Tegelikult ei ole. Paneme hoopis Rain
Õpetaja: Rain on hoopis meil praegu siin. Ee, üks klient Rain. Ma panen oma gamername nii kui sa. Kui mina olen tavaline Customer, mis Number siia tuleb
Õpetaja: kaks. Sellepärast, et ma olen klient. See viitab siin sellele, on nii?
Õpetaja: Nii, mis ma. Mis ma Id väärtuseks? Saan?
Õpetaja: Üks Sellepärast, et ee. Siin tehakse pluss pluss. Ära vaata, et pannakse lihtsalt Üks juurde
Õpetaja: ja see väärtus saadakse nüüd kui juhtub niimoodi, et siin Midagi kustutatakse ja siis tuleb siia klient.
Õpetaja: Näiteks. See vana kustutati ära. Siis mis? On minu. Mis number siia tuleb?
Õpetaja: Kas kaks või kolm, Kolm, üks, kaks ei tule.
Õpetaja: See on juba võetud. Chickens Counter tuimalt paneb lihtsalt edasi
Õpetaja: Sellega garanteeritakse lõputu unikaalsus, sest numbrid teatavasti ei lõppe kunagi.
Õpetaja: Milline on kõige viimane number? Numbrites?
Õpetaja: Lõpmatus ei ole lõpmatus. Pluss üks.
Õpetaja: Nii Ei, on küll nii Jah, et siis kui tuleks keegi kustutaks midagi, siis see protsess on sama. Pannakse kõigepealt üks juurde. Seda numbrit kasutatakse.
Õpetaja: On siin kohal küsimusi.
Õpetaja: Need ongi need Id D, Kui Meil oleks Tabel Cities pärnu. Tallinn Tartu. Need on need viited.
Õpetaja: Niimoodi seotakse andmeid. No ma teen korra nüüd siis siia, nagu päriselt. Noh, Paneme siis Advin ka
Õpetaja: Admin. Tema parool on ka üks, kaks, kolm. Väga turvaline
Õpetaja: staatus on Active. See, et ta ei ole meil kuidagi välja lülitatud. Noh, kustutada teda ei taha. See Id jäi siin Panemata. Ennem siis admin saab siin oma rolliks
Õpetaja: üks püks ja siia tuleb
Õpetaja: Kaks Kaks on ju? No praegu läheb järjest. Loe, Vaata, on nii lihtne vaadata seda. Aga ta. Kust ta tuli? Ta tuli sellest. Chickens Counter ist onju.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: panen kinni. Ma arvan, et siit rohkem küsimusi ei ole. Vaatame hiljem edasi. Siin öeldakse, et see login rolliga, kasutab Andmebaasis neid tabeleid. Täpselt Niuksed. Nagu Excel is. Me nägime niuksed. Tabelid on andmebaasis. Okei, Fine.
Õpetaja: Ee, Vaata Mis taaski ütleb? Ee, loo, ee, Loo sisselogimise vaade. Kaldkriips, login. Ee, suuremaks ee loo. Uus vaatekomponent. Login view aadressil, Login ee lisamenüüsse ka vastav nimega link sisse logimine.
Õpetaja: Andmete Päring back and serverid blogi sisse vajutamisel kontrollitakse, kas kõik väljad on täidetud Kui kumbki väljenda. Kui te loete taaski, te ei loe taaski Kunagi päriselus. Nagu ainult ühe korra, et te loete rahulikult selle kolm korda läbi kõva häälega.
Õpetaja: See on kõige tähtsam osa üldse. Vaata nii, Ee, no meie loeme ühe korra logi sisse. Vajutamisel kontrollitakse kas Kõik väljad on täidetud. Kui kumbki väli on jäänud täitmata, siis kuvatakse teade, et täida kõik väljad. Siin on väikene näide ka
Õpetaja: loo selle jaoks eraldi komponente interview, mis võtab sisse Propsi message. Sellest räägime järgmine nädal. Mis see on,
Õpetaja: Kui Messenger on tühi tühi Strings, siis Alerti ei kuvata. Kui on mingi sisu, siis kuvatakse niuke reaktiivne allergia,
Õpetaja: kui kõik Vajalikud väljad on täidetud. Siis saadetakse back end ile. Http, sõnum, aadressil get, login, Aa, sõnum koos quer Ja request Parameetritega username string Password String Urlis on niikuinii kõik String Id back end I jaoks. Tegelikult on see nagu tähtis näidissaadetavast sõnumist.
Õpetaja: Gets sõnum. See on Http meetod, Räägime sellest võibolla järgmine nädal. Login.
Õpetaja: Küsimärk lõpetab urli. Nüüd on username väärtus. Näiteks läheb sealt admin
Õpetaja: and iga. Lisad nii palju, kui tahad, Neid läheb, ee. Üks, kaks, Kolm
Õpetaja: Back end tagastab sellele päringule, et all järgnevates formaatides Status kakssada. Räägime staatustest. Ka Kakssada Tähendab, kõik on Hästi,
Õpetaja: on kakssada. Üks on kakssada. Kolm on kakssada, neli. Ja igast muid staatuseid on veel üks ühine joon on see, et kakssada, et on. Kõik on hästi.
Õpetaja: Mõni tähendas seda, et lisasin midagi, et andmeid lisati veel ja kõik läks hästi ja nii edasi. Vahet pole, me Vaatame neid oma lihtsuse huvides. Sellel kursusel paneme kõik status kakssada. Ei hakka nagu täpsustama, et kakssada kaks, kakssada, neli, ee ja
Õpetaja: niukeste väljedega User Id. Üks näide user Id. Kaks roll Name customer. Need on näited,
Õpetaja: kui lähevad asjad halvasti. Staatus nelisada, kolm, Noh, nelisada nelja olete näinud.
Õpetaja: Page not found page, not found. Tähendab, et ee tähendab nelisada. Neli Tähendabki Not found mitte page not found, Aga not found
Õpetaja: Backend ei tagastab end, tagastab andmeid. Aga not found on nagu võimalik. Aa, nelisada kolm peaks olema konflikt keelatud.
Õpetaja: Vale kasutaja nimi on Parool. Et tagastab täpselt sellise Jason sõnumi. See ei ole vaikimisi sõnum, mis sa üks Ee Back and server. Muidu tahaks täpselt Custom sõnum, niisugused väljad nagu üks. Üks. See, mille järgi me progeme
Õpetaja: Me ei vaata, Frondis, et. Ei. Mis ma sain vastuse.
Õpetaja: Ma sain vale kasutaja. Nimi parool. Ma pean seda kuvama, aga nagu If ide mõttes, et mida ma näitan või mis peab toimuma seda me mängime selle vastu. Standardlahendus nagu Enamvähem, ee. Kas on mingid staatused või error koodid, Mida iganes kasutatakse. Mingeid niukseid asju.
Õpetaja: Edukas päring vastuses saadud. User Id väärtus salvestatakse session Story Faili Ee faili võtmega. User Id
Õpetaja: vastuses saadud role. Väärtus salvestatakse Session Storage Faili võtmega Role Name võti väärtus. Võti, väärtus, Menüüs peidetakse ära. Sisselogimine ja link menüüsse ilmuv link logi välja. Peale edukat sisselogimist suunatakse kasutajal pangaautomaatide asukohta Vaatajale kaldkriips Htms
Õpetaja: Ee, bla, bla, bla, kui vastuse staatusse. Nüüd vastusega pärin. Kui läheb halvasti.
Õpetaja: Kui vastuse Staatus on nelisada kolm ja sõnumi Jason välja. Error Code väärtus on üks üks Siis kuvada message, veateade vale kasutajanimi või parool. Veateade tuleb võtta error sõnumi message väljalt.
Õpetaja: Nii kui meil oleks mitmekeelsus, siis tegelikult need sõnumid oleks. Ja need tekstid oleksid pigem frontis. Aga meil ei ole mitmekeelsust.
Õpetaja: Saaks ka tegelikult seda hallata. Vahet pole kõikide teiste vigade puhul suunata Kasutaja vaatele. Kaldkriips. Error. Rääkisin teile varemgi. Need asjad on siin. See asi on programmeeritud viga.
Õpetaja: Back end is.
Õpetaja: Vale kasutajaline või Parool. Seda Me teame seda. Me handl Ime
Õpetaja: back end kukub Ee, andmebaas maha
Õpetaja: või kuskil koodis on midagi väga halvasti. Mida Iganes midagi võib sellega Võib juhtuda Mingisuguste andme andmebaasist tulenevad asjad tulevad sellisel viisil, nagu võibolla ei tea. Noh, midagi, mis tekitab mingi konflikti Mida enam, süsteem saab Lihtsalt teha kõikidel teistel olukordade. Juhul, kui ei ole see olukord.
Õpetaja: Aga tuleb viga.
Õpetaja: Ups, midagi läks valesti. Tuumapomb plahvatab või kellegil olid seal Mingid pangad ja mingid asjad, mis iganes.
Õpetaja: Liikumine vaatele, kaldkriips, Htms lehele saabudes peab saama kätte Sees olevad user, Id ja väärtused ning info Kuvama Alert. Noh, ma just natukene Panin sõnu juurde. Infot on võimalik talletada ja vajadusel on see kättesaadav ka teistele vaadatel
Õpetaja: kui kasutaja on sisse loginud. Admin customer. Siis sisse logimine nuppu ei kuvata. Selle asemel kuvatakse logi välja. Nupu Tundub, et siin vist saab veits rohkem teha tööd,
Õpetaja: kui siiamaani. Väga hea, Proovime teha Nii palju siis, kui jõuame. Millest alustame?
Õpetaja: Ee, uus bränz oma haru pealt New Branch.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma Korra ruttu. Vaatan, mis veb see oli Veb seitse.
Õpetaja: Nii, Parabin Paramoom olemas sellega. Nüüd vaatame natuke taas ka üle, et on nagu õiges Järjekorras ka.
Õpetaja: Ahah, jah,
Õpetaja: aga salvestab. Jah, Ee, järgmine asi. Loo Uus vaatekomponent. Login View aadressil login. Noh, öelge teie mulle ja kes tahab Juba Kütku new. View Onju
Õpetaja: Voe Komponent nimi. Oli oota. Vaatame, mis, oli nüüd login. View Oli login suure tähega viu
Õpetaja: seda. Ta Hoiab Kogu aeg meeles veel natukese aega. Me tõstame ise neid templateid asju ümber. Järgmisest nädalast on väikse lahenduse. Saab selle grammi võrra kiiremalt Ee, Selliselt see script tegelikult tuleb lihtsalt alla tõsta. On ju Control Iks
Õpetaja: Style ära kustutada. Control V Ja seda template sinna üleval lõi kokku. Praegu korraks võib Tv panna niikuinii.
Õpetaja: Ee, minu kogemata. Ma vajutan Kit Ad.
Õpetaja: Ta küsis. Vaata, uus fail ja ma kogemata ei pannud. Tähele, Mul on ta punane.
Õpetaja: Ma lähen ütlen lihtsalt niisama käsitsi, et Ee, ad kit ad. Et ta ikka oleks jälgimises.
Õpetaja: Vahet pole,
Õpetaja: ma ei saa sulle vastata. Milline see on? Sa võid, vaadata kui see on. Aga see on nagu. See on nagu mingi kahe nädala vastus Sulle Ma ei saa nagu sealt vastata praegu.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis me nüüd järgmisena teeme?
Õpetaja: Ai Griiti paned kõigepeal.
Õpetaja: Aa, sa küsid kumb neist valida? Või See oli küsimus. Ee. Alati jätke meelde, on valikutega api. See hakkab natuke rohkem nagu selginema, kui struktuuri vaatame. Ma Ei, ma üritan nagu ise mingit, ee, analoogi tuua. Ee, no kes juba. Jõudis ette, Siis tegi. Aga mis järgmine samm on? Kui teeme uue vaate, siis alati,
Õpetaja: Noh, Noh, Kaili.
Õpetaja: Ei, ma tegelikult mõtlesin seda, et Artur juba ütles. Vaata, tal on uus nimeselts, mis me teeme?
Õpetaja: Muidugi teeme lahti, see on isegi siin? Meeldivalt ees.
Õpetaja: Vajume vajutame Nuppu. Tuleb see vana hea.
Õpetaja: Kolme kolumniga.
Õpetaja: Div korra võib nüüd vaadata ka.
Õpetaja: Mis te mõtlete, mitu Kolumnit on vaja Siin lahenduses.
Õpetaja: Ühte kolumit on vaja.
Õpetaja: Tavaly tundub.
Õpetaja: Ei, ei ole vaja. Mitut rida
Õpetaja: saaks aga Kohe, kindlalt ei taha.
Õpetaja: Ära Mõtle, et see iga osa on rida. Ainult siis, kui on vaja.
Õpetaja: Kui siin oleks näiteks kaks kolumnit ja allpool üks kolumn, siis on Selle point I. Me saame kõik ühte kolumnisse panna. Ja Css iga nagu manageerida, et nad on üksteise all.
Õpetaja: Ühesõnaga, selle kolumni võib siis praegu siin lihtsalt täita. Hetkel login View ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, tekstina. Ega see kohe niikuinii läheb sealt minema. Ee, me hakkame siin midagi tegema. Ka ju
Õpetaja: nii kui nüüd see login. View Vaade on olemas. Vaatame, mis veel loo. Uus vaatekomponent Log in View, mis avaneb aadressil kaldkriips. Login. Mis Teeme
Õpetaja: ruuter Ruuteri indeks.
Õpetaja: Mis siin tublikeid see osa Ärge tehke. Copy Based Lihtsalt aga valige täpselt. Näete, see on üks komponent,
Õpetaja: võtsid selle koma siis järgmisele ette. No niipidi saaks ka. Vaata aga, nagu parem on niipidi tublid käit.
Õpetaja: See oli, onju?
Õpetaja: Noh, selle Ruudi nimi. On
Õpetaja: selle kontrol kaks isv ka siniseks. Deliit. Mis on need tähed, mis võiksid sinna kirjutada? Järgmisena lv. Suurte tähtedega
Õpetaja: pakub loogi, on õigel asjal. No võime hoolega üles alla liikuda. Valida selle siit Sellega on kõik
Õpetaja: nüüd saab kohe proovida.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma panen selle siia kõrvale, kes tahab koodi vaadata, siis teeme niimoodi. Ee, saab proovida.
Õpetaja: Tulen siit sellest vaatan. Ee, ahhaa. Noh, ma saan proovida urliga. Kaldkriips. Ee tuleb, Ee, tuleb,
Õpetaja: aga taaskis on loomulikult nõutud, et ee, et siia saaks ka tulla. Kuidas
Õpetaja: lisamenüüsse ka vastav link nimega sisse logimine, Kuhu läheme.
Õpetaja: Aa Poe
Õpetaja: tempo on natuke suur, aga minuteid on vähe. Vaata, vahet pole, saate kõik ära. Kui te kodus veel mõelda vaadata. Proovime pigem teha, et äkki jõuab veel mõne kontseptsiooniga õpetada. Ee, up poest, et hästi lihtsalt arendada. Mis mõtted on? Vaatan, kus see link asuma peab üldse.
Õpetaja: Ta peab olema peale pangaautomaate kõige viimane, mis mõtted on.
Õpetaja: Jah, mis siin? Ma ütlen, nagu, Kuidas ee, ga tööd teha.
Õpetaja: Noh, tublike, oled sellel real ära. Selle Ärge hakake seda jama tegema. Siin pole vaja Kui ühte Kui tahad mitut rida, siis on vaja nagu Dublitseerida, ükskõik Kuhugi. Siia, Control D.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Juba teed keyboard iga. Liigud siia kontrolliga niimoodi varem asemele. See siin on loogiline. Võite praegu ka hiirega. Pess Oleks ruttu tehtud ja siia pidi tulema. Sisselogimine vist. Oli Onju sussse lugemine.
Õpetaja: Just jah, noh, mida iganes Ee. Mida iganes
Õpetaja: tulete, tuleta minule järgi. Küll te siis olete. Sisse logimine, Ee, logimine. Mida iganes, aga logi sisse ka. Kuidas kõnetab? Vahet pole seal teie ennustada, kuidas te Teete asju, Aga peamine asi on see, et see link on olemas,
Õpetaja: Saab kohe vaadata ka. Ma panen jälle siis kõrvale, et saate senikaua siin vaadata.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui keegi midagi tahab vaadata, et kui ma tulen kodu.
Õpetaja: Pangaautomaadid sisse logimine, mis hetkel lihtsalt näitab, Login View Fine sobib,
Õpetaja: Kui tuli mingi error, siis saad sellega kodus maadelda. Praegu meil ei ole kindlat aega.
Õpetaja: Ee, võid. Vaata, ütleme, siis võib lihtsalt edasi vaadata. Pole Point I. Vaata, meil on vaja edasi liikuda. Tegelt natuke tempoga. Peame kuidagi saama, eks? Ma jääpin ja räägin ka asju, onju? Nii? Ee, mis järgmisena? Ee Vaatame, mis taask ütleb.
Õpetaja: Aa, taas järgmisena ütleb, et andmete pärimine Back End Ilse vajutamisel kontrollitakse, kas kõik väljad on täidetud. Okei, nüüd teeme rohkem nagu teooriat. See on natukene niisama. Aa, me ei jõua niikuinii siin seda asja ära teha, siis Ma teen Seda, mis ma pean vajalikuks.
Õpetaja: Kui me taha teeme ühe nupu lihtsalt siia. Aa, selle asemele paneme.
Õpetaja: Patt. On.
Õpetaja: Patt. On objekt. Valige see Patt on submit. Näiteks nupule. Paneme lihtsalt login. View Ee hello world.
Õpetaja: See nupp on igati kole ja nii edasi. Kes tahab, võib ruttu Class iga teha selle mingiks normaalsemaks kirjutades. Class,
Õpetaja: Ptn. Ja näiteks Ptn. Outline Sekundary vist on siin ja
Õpetaja: mida iganes see ei ole tähtis ka ausõna. See. See nupp on ajutine. Tegelikult Vaatamise koht. Mis te siin ikka klõbistate?
Õpetaja: On siin nupp.
Õpetaja: Ju on ka valesti. No see Mind häirib, kas olla nüüd, kuidas seda nuppu saab käivitada ja mida me tahame käivitada selle nupuga.
Õpetaja: Ärme mõte nagu pikalt, öelda, mida me Lihtsalt nagu ma räägin süntaksi mõttes. Ja, ee mõttes, mida me tahame sellega käivitada?
Õpetaja: Aa, ei, Ei, Ära nüüd mine äriloogikasse.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma räägin Nüüd puhtalt programmeerimine. Javascript. Mida? Mida see asi peaks käivitama?
Õpetaja: Aeg saada Ja te räägite kogu seda lõpptulemust? Ma küsin hoopis midagi muud,
Õpetaja: kui me tegime kunagi seda kunagi. Jah, alles üleeile tegime. Aa, räägi jah. Okei, Peaaegu vähemalt üks sõna oli. See on õige. Meetod, See peaks käivitama funktsiooni. Aga mulle meeldib sõna meetod. Kuna nüüd me oleme voes
Õpetaja: Jaavascript, Ma mõtlen, et see nupp peaks käivitama mingi funktsiooni,
Õpetaja: see oli see mõte. Aga nüüd hakkame õppima. Siis api võludega, mis meil on. Näete, seda.
Õpetaja: Siin on? Hetkel lihtsalt öeldakse et kogu ülejäänud maailm aa Näeb seda lihtsalt seda komponenti, kui nimega Login View.
Õpetaja: Nüüd siin on erinevad asjad. Pange koma ajal, Siis on erinevad igasugused sektsioonid ja Option Id. Igasugused valikud,
Õpetaja: mis me saame siin teha. Üks nendest valikutest on Methods metsad.
Õpetaja: Nüüd väikene trikk teile arendaja elusse,
Õpetaja: kui teil on mingi Niukene asi, Mis on mitmuses, Siis te peate mõtlema seda, et kui ma saan mitu asja kirjutada, kas nad ühele reale mahuksid? Tee järgi ära. Ja mida kuradit me siin üldse kirjutame?
Õpetaja: Kui asjad ikka väga ei taha? Kuidagi ühele reale ära mahtuda Võibolla on mõni asi, mis Kuidagi justkui võiks mahtuda. Siis on vaja kuidagi defineerida. Koodis ulatus. Noh, mis on Javascriptis ja javas kõige lihtsam lahendus kuidas saab mingitele asjadele Anda ulatust ehk skoopi?
Õpetaja: Kas loogiliselt või? Okei, okei,
Õpetaja: tubli. Ee. Nüüd, kuidas see käib? Näete, siin seda on mingi blokk ja siis tuleb talle,
Õpetaja: Mis sellele blokile nüüd kool järgneb, on loojalised sulud.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et kirjutame funktsioone. Nii et tapab nii, et ninast verd lendab.
Õpetaja: Kuidas sa Selle ühele reale kirjutad? Pole õrna aimu, aga vihje oli selles sis. Tegelikult see mujal ka. Jaevas.
Õpetaja: Aa, teine kord, Ma leian neid kohti. Vaata, kus saab öelda. Vaadake, sinu mitmuses mitmus tähendab mingisugust palju asju. Kuidas saab palju asju kuidagi ära defineerida? Ma võin sulle ühe reale ka kokku panna.
Õpetaja: Nüüd mäletate seda? Vee Funktsioon algab sõnaga. Function
Õpetaja: Voe saab selle lisamisega ise väga hästi hakkama. Seda saab igat meetodil erinevalt kirjutada. Valikut ei olegi siis Composition Api S ei ole kogu seda osa. Põhimõtteliselt.
Õpetaja: Aa, siin on Jumal tänatud. Mulle meeldib, see on hästi struktureeritud. Nüüd me saame lihtsalt kirjutada meetodi nime. Kohe Funktsiooni ei pea panema. Selle ta teeb ise.
Õpetaja: Me saame öelda lihtsalt Noh, paneme lihtsalt Praegu see on vaatamine. Muidugi, Hello.
Õpetaja: Hello World.
Õpetaja: Sest et seda nuppu ennast ka ei tule meil
Õpetaja: nüüd. Niipea kui me selle ära tegime, Võtsin Control Shift Enter. Ta tegi automaatselt Ära mulle koodibloki ja pani koma ka otsa.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Hello World I. Ma võin teha lihtsalt lihtlabase Alerdi.
Õpetaja: Tere, maailm.
Õpetaja: Nii, Mida see Hall viitab?
Õpetaja: Poole kasutuses. Mäletate nupule. Me panime Niukse atribuudi äärde, nagu on. Click, on ju,
Õpetaja: aga see on puhas Html. Aa, siin on natukene üks teine. Asi. Siin oleks pikalt. Ma näitan korra talle. Voe, asi Voe
Õpetaja: on kool. On click Nii siin. Me teeks seda poes. Thank God, Seda osa saab natuke lühemalt teha.
Õpetaja: Ät click, Nii, Ja nüüd. Kui see Ad kliki tulla kontroll tühiks, siis ta pakub
Õpetaja: voemeetodid. Default Methods, Login View.
Õpetaja: Hello, World Jälle login, View.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Sellel nupul on see funktsionaalsus kui sina klikid Sellele nupi nupule käivitub see asi meetodi blokis. Vaata, kui lühikeselt saime kirjutada ka mingi.
Õpetaja: Noh, toredad asjad. Muidugi on alles veel Tulemas, ma Vajutan siia Peale tuleb. Tere, maailm.
Õpetaja: Olete nõus?
Õpetaja: Okei, cool. Cool, cool, cool.
Õpetaja: Nii, ee, nüüd. Las see Hello World Korraks olla
Õpetaja: mängime. Me Teeme seda sama asja nüüd. Meil on ju mingid kastid. Esiteks kastid. Kui me tahame tekitada. Nüüd me tahame korra taaski teha. Jälle nüüd on kaasategemise koht
Õpetaja: võib ka tegelikult olla vaatamise koht. Siis ma tegelikult üritan jõuda võibolla ühe mõtteharjutuseni. Ma teen seda natukene praegu, et ise sobib.
Õpetaja: Ma võtan praegult mingit inputid ja ma teen hästi labaselt. Ma ei tee seda lõpuni ära. Ee, input
Õpetaja: ja see sama siin see Kast lihtsalt input koos Ee, mingi selgitusega. Mulle see variant ei meeldi. Me vahetame selle pärast välja, aga praegult sobib küll selle nupu ma Jätan
Õpetaja: selle nupu. Ma jätan ee, input tekst. Glass. Username Place Order. Username kõik. Isegi Tegelikult enamvähem sobib. Lähme ruttu, vaatame, Username kogu ulatus.
Õpetaja: Tühja temaga, et ta on pikk. Praegult Unustame selle ära, on ju?
Õpetaja: Okei, Teen selle ruttu ka korda. Ee, panen koolile juurde. Ee, et ole. Sina Ainult mina ei tea. Nii. Suur
Õpetaja: ta on. Vasakul pool. Ee, ma tahan Ainult jõuda kontseptsioonini Mõtteharjutuseni. Panen siia kasutajanimi.
Õpetaja: Nii Kasutajanimi on Siin see kasutajanimi. No sellises stiilis, nagu on. Aa ühtlasi ma panen siia juurde. Teen Täpselt samasuguse asja. Dublitseerin.
Õpetaja: Jah, ja pane mitte Kasutaja nimi, vaid parool.
Õpetaja: Nii, ee, nupu nime. Ma panen Ruttu Login lihtsalt, onju?
Õpetaja: Parool.
Õpetaja: Okei, põmm olemas. Parool Place Holder It ei panegi Nii,
Õpetaja: aa Kustutan üldse lõpuks ära Selle Ma võtan siit ka selle ära. Nii, las olla lihtsalt niimoodi. Ainult kontseptsioon.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Kui mina, vajutan seda nuppu login,
Õpetaja: siis käivitub mingisugune action. Kujutame ette, et see oleks nüüd, et saada sõnum Backendi
Õpetaja: Ee, niiöelda login onju See on visuaalne pool. See on kõik visuaalne pool, Aga see alumine pool on action.
Õpetaja: Käivita midagi Script Ja nüüd. Mina tahan teha teile väikse harjutuse
Õpetaja: Ee Voh, väga hea. Mul on hea meel. Me jõuame nii kaugele.
Õpetaja: Ee, võtan pildid.
Õpetaja: Aa, ma korra, nagu tõmban nagu natuke asju kokku. Kas Vastab tõele, et siin on Niuke Template osa ja on script. Osa.
Õpetaja: Template osa on see pool, mida me näeme.
Õpetaja: Aa Scriptos on, see Kus me saame teha tegevusi? Nii, hoidke see meeles, on ju Meil on kaks blokki. Template Block ja script blokk.
Õpetaja: Meil on kaks maailma Visuaalne pool ja mingisugune tegevus.
Õpetaja: Mingisugune tegevus. Mingisugune toiming. Mida iganes,
Õpetaja: Ee Nüüd, Ee, Mina võtan lahti pildi vajablokid
Õpetaja: ehitust. Mehi on, millega on tegemist. Mis asi on,
Õpetaja: Blokk? Fibo, Blokk või Kolumbia kivi. Vahet pole. Vaata, blokk. See saab mingit tsementi sisse valada ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Meil On üks blokk üleval, mis on template
Õpetaja: Ja meil on üks teine blokk all, mis on.
Õpetaja: Nägite seal skriptis oli ju mehtus seal saab Action eit teha oli nii.
Õpetaja: Ei, minu küsimus on see, et, ee,
Õpetaja: mis ühendab seda kahte maailma, mis on ühendav lüli nende kahe maailma vahel,
Õpetaja: et meil on visuaalne pool ja meil on tegevused, mida nad jagavad.
Õpetaja: Tegevust Ei, tegevus on tegevus. On lihtsalt tegevus. Tegevus on all,
Õpetaja: Okei, väga hea. Mis asi on info
Õpetaja: teise sõnaga? No, kes on andmed?
Õpetaja: Te hakkasite väga kiirelt ära. Kui ma võibolla natuke. Sõnastasin küsimuse Lihtsamalt ka nüüd
Õpetaja: see asi. See asi siin on nüüd selline asi, et need kaks osa, mis meil on ja kogu üldse, kogu üldse, See tehnoloogia
Õpetaja: rajaneb sellele keskmisele kivile.
Õpetaja: Andmed, ainukene moodus, kuidas need kaks maailma omavahel saavad? Tegelikult, suhelda on läbi andmete,
Õpetaja: Kui sa soovid näha mingisuguseid andmeid seal visuaalis.
Õpetaja: Siis peab käima mingi. No mõtlema on ju? Kui sa soovid seal visuaalis mingeid andmeid näidata,
Õpetaja: siis peab käivitama mingi Tegevus, mis toob need andmed ära ja siis läind. Näitame seal.
Õpetaja: Kui sul on seal mingi vorm, mida sa seal visuaalsel poolel täidad ja Sa soovid neid andmeid. Kas siis lisada või nendega antud juhul näiteks sisse logida?
Õpetaja: Siis sa pead käivitama mingi tegevuse
Õpetaja: ja see keskel, nende Vahel ongi andmed.
Õpetaja: Mul on taotluslikult tehtud see blokkide värk niimoodi, et niimoodi eraldiseisvalt
Õpetaja: need asjad omavahel nagu tervikut ei moodusta ja ei ole Võimelised toimima.
Õpetaja: Ja eelkõige on see, et kogu see tehnoloogia ee rajaneb. Andmetel.
Õpetaja: Andmed on see, mis juhib seda, mida me näeme,
Õpetaja: kuidas kuidas asju kuvatakse. Ja mida seal põhimõtteliselt teha saab?
Õpetaja: Andmed ühte või teistpidi.
Õpetaja: Vahet pole, kas meil siis on mingid andmed, mis tulevad sealt Visuaalist Ja nendega peab midagi tegema. Või on mingisugused andmed, mida me peame hagema ja kuskilt ära tooma. Ja, noh, miks me neid hageme ja Toome ära, sest me soovime neid. Kuvada
Õpetaja: Siin on Niukene süsteem. See reaktiivsus põhinebki. Siis andmeobjektidel, et meil on niuksed erilised muutujad,
Õpetaja: mis on Reaktiivsed reaktiivsed. Selles mõttes, et voe kogu aeg jälgib nende andmete sisu
Õpetaja: Kui mul on seal mingisugune first name
Õpetaja: Niukene muutuja, siis ta ei Ole lihtsalt muutuja,
Õpetaja: vaid on selline muutuja, mida voe jälgib ja tema jälgib muudatusi.
Õpetaja: Kui seal on sees, näiteks Rail
Õpetaja: siis seal sees on Rain Ja kõik on nii, nagu on. On ju? Kui seal tuleb üks tähemärk juurde või läheb üks tähemärk vähemaks
Õpetaja: või muutub ühe tähemärgi, mingi. Ma ei tea, Case. Mis iganes
Õpetaja: siis voe näeb, et toimus muudatus
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd vastavalt sellele, kuidas meil on asjad programmeeritud,
Õpetaja: siis ta Nüüd teab, kas ta peab midagi kuskil uuesti
Õpetaja: koodis renderdama. Kas ta peab midagi uuesti näitama või mitte,
Õpetaja: Sa pead midagi htm is teistmoodi tegema.
Õpetaja: See ongi see nipp. Kuidas nad on nagu teinud selle asja ära, et Kuidas toimub väga palju niukest interaktiivsust niimoodi, et me kuskilt Tegelikult otseselt ei programmeeri asju niimoodi sellisel kujul, et
Õpetaja: et. Ee, ole ole hea nü. Nüüd, värskendaja, Ehita see tabel uuesti.
Õpetaja: Programmiliselt seda seda Ei, toimu ei ole. Me Ainult programmeerime selle ära. Et Hei, ee, siia tuleb. Tabel.
Õpetaja: Sina saad oma tabelit, selle muutuja seest ja ongi Kõik,
Õpetaja: kui algselt seal ei ole mitte midagi. Leht laetakse. No alg väärtus võib ka panna
Õpetaja: algärdselt. Ma ei tea, tabelis näitasin mingi ühte Rida või kahte rida Ära mitte midagi, siis täpselt seda ta teeb.
Õpetaja: Ta näitab seda, mida peab näitama.
Õpetaja: Ja kui nüüd juhuslikult midagi nendes andmetes, nagu muutub. Ma toon lihtlabase näite. Kui meil on neid pangaautomaatide asukohtasi kolm tükki
Õpetaja: kolm rida.
Õpetaja: Nad elavad kuskil muutujas nimega Htm. Locations,
Õpetaja: Kui seal on nagu massiiv Jason taga, põhimõtteliselt koos andmetega, kus on kolm objekti,
Õpetaja: siis ta kuvab kolm rida. Kui nüüd mingil põhjusel peab Seal Muutujas Sellele muutujale määratakse uus sisu.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd järsku on seal hoopis. Kas siis kaks objekti või või? Aa, neli objekti või viis objekti. Vahet pole,
Õpetaja: ta näeb, et andmetes on toimunud muudatus.
Õpetaja: Järelikult Html tuleb uuesti genereerida Tabelite road.
Õpetaja: Saate mõttest aru
Õpetaja: No te hakkate veel selles mõttes aru saama. Selles mõttes, et ee. Veel läheb natukene aega. Uuel nädalal hakkamegi seda vaatama. Väikene ka teiser
Õpetaja: diaser. Id on alati Siis on mida oodata.
Õpetaja: Saaks see nädalavahetus juba läbi ja tuleks. Esmaspäev.
Õpetaja: Kas on äkki see Exceli kujul? Ma pakun, ei ole, see
Õpetaja: ahah
Õpetaja: Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja
Õpetaja: ei.
Õpetaja: Kus on front?
Õpetaja: Oi, see on vana, aga. Okei, Näete, Ee, seda Koske
Õpetaja: kosk voolab ülevalt alla. Mul on Kuskil parem, et see on vananenud Ja näete seda tuvi.
Õpetaja: See kosk sümboliseerib edaspidi meil pidevalt
Õpetaja: seda kuidas andmed voolavad ülevalt alla,
Õpetaja: ja kuidas Kõik alamkomponendid siis vajadusel ise renderdavad ja joonistavad Html koodi lihtsalt vajalikus osas uuesti.
Õpetaja: Ja kui meil on vaja nagu mingisuguseid muudatusi
Õpetaja: et asjad Nagu peaksid kuidagi, et andmed peavad, et andmed saavad uueneda.
Õpetaja: Aga andmed ei saa uueneda alt, vaid andmed saavad alati uueneda ja muutuda ülevalt.
Õpetaja: Aga õnneks on meil niuke väikene tuvi Jälle Me saame iga kell teele panna. Laseme puurist lahti
Õpetaja: ja üleval. Kuskil üleval on keegi, kes ootab teda oma puuriga,
Õpetaja: püüab kinni ja kui ta püüab selle kinni, siis ta vaatab seda sõnumit, mis tal on jala külge pandud
Õpetaja: ja Siis ta teab sellest, et nüüd peab midagi teistmoodi tegema.
Õpetaja: Vahel tal on pakikene ka kaasas
Õpetaja: Vahe oleneb lisaks sõnumile Mingisuguse paki ka üle
Õpetaja: saavad olema meil sellised tegelased nagu Props ja Emit Davai aitab tänaseks. Kuidas see nädal oli kokkuvõttes
Õpetaja: lihtne. Väga hea, väga hea, Hakkame midagi tegema ka. Jah, ma olen nõus.